If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the restishistory.com and click Gifts. This episode is sponsored by Hive. History has always been a story of power. Who seeks it, who seizes it, and how easily it can all slip away. The Caesars, the Caliphs, the Tsars, they conquered vast swaths of the world, they reclaimed themselves, the favourites of the gods, and yet their empires crumbled away. It is easier to conquer than it is to control.
如果您想了解更多节目内容，请加入“历史即是一切”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）。随着圣诞节的临近，您也可以为您生命中热爱历史的人送上一整年的会员资格。只需前往therestishistory.com并点击“礼物”（Gifts）即可。本期节目由Hive赞助。历史一直是一个关于权力的故事。谁在寻求权力，谁在攫取权力，以及权力又是如何轻易地溜走的。凯撒、哈里发、沙皇，他们征服了广袤的土地，他们自诩为神的宠儿，然而他们的帝国最终还是土崩瓦解了。征服比控制要容易得多。
Hive takes a different approach. It puts power where it belongs in your hands. They started with smart thermostats and they've now gone. much further. Solar panels, heat pumps, EV charges, all working together so that you can power your home in your own way. That's genuine empowerment. Checking your phone, seeing the heating's on, the car's charging and the sun is quietly earning its keep on the roof. Caesar never had to charge his chariots, but I'm sure he would have admired the efficiency. Visit hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability, hive compatible with selected technology.
Hive采取了不同的方式。它将权力交还给它所属的地方——也就是您的手中。他们从智能恒温器起家，现在已经走得更远了。太阳能电池板、热泵、电动汽车充电桩，所有这些设备协同工作，让您可以按照自己的方式为家庭供电。这才是真正的赋权。查看手机，看到暖气开着，汽车正在充电，屋顶上的太阳能板正在静静地为您创造价值。凯撒从未需要给他的战车充电，但我相信他一定会钦佩这种效率。访问hivehome.com了解更多信息。需视勘察和适用性而定，Hive兼容特定技术。
And I acknowledge that thou hast dealt as wonderfully and as mercifully with me as thou didst with thy true and faithful servant, Daniel, thy prophet, whom thou deliveranceed out of the den from the cruelty of the greedy and raging lions. Even so was I overwhelmed, and only by thee delivered. To thee only be thanks, honor, and praise forever. Amen. So that was Queen Elizabeth I, Gloriana, the Virgin Queen, on the 14th of January 1559. Two months into her reign, two months after her sister, Bloody Mary, has died leaving her as the heir. And she is speaking to a crowd who've gathered outside the Tower of London. So that is the place where her mother had been imprisoned and had died, where she had been imprisoned. and had feared for her own life and where she is now staying in the royal apartments waiting for her coronation. And Tom, you suggest in your notes that she's thinking about Daniel and the
我承认，你对我所施的奇妙与仁慈，正如你对你那忠诚的仆人、你的先知但以理所做的一样，你将他从贪婪而狂暴的狮子口中拯救出来。我亦曾深陷困境，唯有你将我拯救。愿荣耀、尊贵和赞美永远归于你。阿门。以上是伊丽莎白一世女王，即“光荣女王”、“童贞女王”，于1559年1月14日所说的话。那是她即位两个月后，也是她姐姐“血腥玛丽”去世两个月后，玛丽留下了她作为继承人。她当时正在对聚集在伦敦塔外的人群讲话。那是她母亲曾被囚禁并死去的地方，也是她自己曾被囚禁、曾为自己的生命担忧的地方，而现在她正住在皇家公寓里等待加冕。汤姆，你在笔记中提到她想到了但以理和
lion's den because Tower of the London has a menagerie, an exciting sort of proto zoo. Yeah, with lions. And she's been thinking about lions because of that. That's nice. Well, I'd just throw that out as a possibility. And it's a great speech. And, you know, she is alluding to all the traumas and dangers that you were you were mentioning and she's still only 25 but she has pulled through and I think that by casting herself as Daniel saved from the lion's den I mean it's an absolutely brilliant humble brag because on the one hand she's saying oh it's only thanks to god that I've survived but of course if she is like Daniel who was a prophet who was spared by God to work out his purposes then it suggests that Elizabeth also has been spared deliberately by
狮子坑，因为伦敦塔里有一个动物园，一种令人兴奋的原始动物园。是的，里面有狮子。她因为这个想到了狮子。这很有意思。好吧，我只是把它作为一个可能性提出来。这是一场精彩的演讲。而且，你知道，她是在影射你提到的所有创伤和危险，她当时才25岁，但她挺过来了。我认为，通过将自己比作从狮子坑中获救的但以理，这绝对是一种极其高明的“凡尔赛”式谦逊，因为一方面，她说这完全归功于上帝的保佑，但另一方面，如果她像但以理那样，是一位被上帝拯救以完成其旨意的先知，那么这暗示着伊丽莎白也是被上帝刻意保留下来的，
God and has great purposes ahead of her. So to quote Helen Casta, who has a brilliant short biography of Elizabeth about this speech, it was a rhetoric and reality fused into a performance that was at once immediately legible and utterly unreadable. So that sense in which Elizabeth is brilliant at speaking, at coming up with phrases and images and ideas that resonate with her subjects, but at the same time keeping her own thoughts and personality completely veiled. Classic display of Elizabethan rhetoric. And right from the start, she proves an absolute master at something that her father, Henry of the Eighth, had been brilliance at, which is the theatre of monarchy, the pageantry,
并肩负着伟大的使命。引用海伦·卡斯塔（Helen Casta）的话，她有一本关于伊丽莎白这篇演讲的精彩短传，这是一种将修辞与现实融合在一起的表演，既直白易懂，又完全令人捉摸不透。伊丽莎白擅长演讲，擅长构思那些能与臣民产生共鸣的短语、意象和思想，但同时又将自己的真实想法和个性完全隐藏起来。这是伊丽莎白式修辞的经典展示。从一开始，她就证明了自己是她父亲亨利八世所擅长之事的绝对大师，那就是君主制的戏剧性、盛大的排场，
the spectacle, because she's carried, isn't she, from the tower in a litter to Westminster, and there are pageants and kind of tableau all along the way, and the public are lying the streets, They absolutely love it. Anyone familiar with the reign of Henry the Eighth will know that he loved all this and he was brilliant at it. And so is she. She has that quality that you absolutely need as a kind of early modern ruler, which is to be a superb public performer.
以及奇观，因为她被从伦敦塔用轿子抬往威斯敏斯特，沿途有各种庆典和场景展示，公众挤满了街道，他们绝对喜欢这些。任何熟悉亨利八世统治时期的人都知道他热爱这一切，并且非常擅长此道。她也是如此。她具备作为一名早期现代统治者所绝对需要的素质，那就是成为一名出色的公众表演者。
Yeah. And I think that procession from the tower to a coronation is a popularity test. And of course, it was one that her mother, Anne Berlin, when she went to be crowned as queen, had failed. But Elizabeth spectacularly passes it to quote a contemporary witness. London had become a stage wherein was showed the wonderful spectacle of a noble-hearted princess toward her most loving people and the people's exceeding comfort beholding so worthy a sovereign. And the next day, after this procession, she goes to Westminster
是的。我认为从伦敦塔到加冕礼的游行是一场人气测试。当然，这也是她母亲安妮·博林在被加冕为王后时失败的一场测试。但伊丽莎白出色地通过了。引用一位当代目击者的话：“伦敦变成了一个舞台，展示了一位心地高尚的公主对她最可爱的臣民的奇妙景象，而臣民们在看到如此值得尊敬的君主时感到无比欣慰。”在游行的第二天，她前往威斯敏斯特
Abbey, her hair long and Auburn is flowing and this is to symbolise her virginity. And in Westminster Abbey, she is crowned and people who listen to our episode on Dr. John D., her necroman her astrologer. He had chosen the day because it was a propitious one. And it's clear that Elizabeth felt it as being exactly that. So the Venetian ambassador saw her coming out from the coronation and said she looked far too happy that her smile was very undignified for a queen. But obviously she was delighted by it. And this is despite the fact that as she well knew, the challenges that faced her and England were absolutely overwhelming. So to give an example, A fact I learned from your notes, which is a brilliant fact, actually,
修道院，她那长长的赤褐色头发披散着，这象征着她的童贞。在威斯敏斯特修道院，她被加冕了。听过我们关于她的占星家约翰·迪博士（Dr. John D.）那期节目的听众应该知道，他选择了这一天，因为这是一个吉日。很明显，伊丽莎白也感受到了这一点。威尼斯大使看到她从加冕礼出来时说，她看起来太高兴了，对于一位女王来说，她的笑容太不庄重了。但显然她对此感到非常欣喜。尽管她很清楚，她和英国所面临的挑战是极其严峻的。举个例子，我从你的笔记中学到的一个事实，实际上是一个非常精彩的事实，
is that she is not crowned by any of the kind of big bishops. She's crowned by somebody who I didn't even know existed. It was the Bishop of Carlisle. Because basically all of the heavyweights say, I don't like this. You know, she's going to be using heretical evangelical stuff in her coronation, and we don't want to be tainted by it. Yeah, because the bishops are all Catholic. Right.
那就是她并不是由任何大主教加冕的。她是由一个我甚至不知道其存在的人加冕的。那是卡莱尔主教。因为基本上所有的大人物都说：“我不喜欢这样。”你知道，她在加冕礼上要使用异端的福音派那一套，我们不想被它玷污。是的，因为主教们都是天主教徒。没错。
So this is a hint of the enduring religious problems that have been going on now for what, 25 years. It still hasn't quite solidified into very simplistic Protestants versus Catholics. But there is this sort of sense clearly, obviously because she's a very, very keen evangelical by birth, by education, by temperament, that the pendulum is now unbelievably after five years swinging back again away from Catholicism. So people who were saying in the sort of 1530s, God, you don't know where you are these days with Henry the 8th and his wives and his changes of religious policy. I mean, things have only got worse for them, because the pendulum is now swinging wildly
所以这暗示了已经持续了25年的宗教问题。它还没有完全固化为简单的“新教徒对阵天主教徒”。但显然有一种感觉，因为她天生、受教育程度和性格上都是一位非常坚定的福音派信徒，钟摆在五年后又不可思议地摆回了远离天主教的方向。所以那些在16世纪30年代说“天哪，在亨利八世和他的妻子们以及他不断变化的宗教政策下，你根本不知道自己身处何方”的人，我的意思是，情况对他们来说只会更糟，因为钟摆现在正疯狂地
and madly one way or another. I think she is Protestant by private conviction. I mean, her private thoughts are always very hard to pin down, but I think she was a committed evangelical. But even if she wasn't, there is no way that she is going to allow the Pope to maintain his supremacy over the English church, because she, Elizabeth, as the daughter of Henry VIII and Anne Berlin, is the living fruit of Henry's break with Rome. There's no way that she can, you know, allow the papal supremacy to continue. And it's very telling that on her way from the Tower to
向一个或另一个方向剧烈摆动。我认为她私下里是新教徒。我的意思是，她的私人想法总是很难确定，但我认为她是一位坚定的福音派信徒。但即使她不是，她也绝不可能允许教皇维持他对英国教会的至高无上地位，因为她，伊丽莎白，作为亨利八世和安妮·博林的女儿，是亨利与罗马决裂的活生生的果实。她绝不可能允许教皇的至高无上地位继续存在。非常能说明问题的是，在她从伦敦塔前往
Westminster, the day before her coronation, with all they were saying, all the crowd's cheering her. One of the cries from the crowd is, remember old king Henry the 8th. And it's recorded that when Elizabeth hears people shout this, again, she smiles. But, To take on the Catholic hierarchy that Mary has spent her reign kind of reinstalling and strengthening, this is a massive challenge, because it's not just in the church, but also in Parliament and in the universities, that the commanding heights of the establishment are occupied by very fervent, very brilliant, very committed Catholics. And on top of that, as we were mentioning in the previous episode, it's also the fact that I think
威斯敏斯特的路上，也就是加冕礼的前一天，人群都在为她欢呼。人群中的呼喊声之一是：“记住老国王亨利八世。”据记载，当伊丽莎白听到人们这样喊时，她又笑了。但是，要对抗玛丽在位期间重新建立和加强的天主教等级制度，这是一个巨大的挑战，因为这不仅是在教会中，而且在议会和大学里，建制派的指挥高地都被非常狂热、非常聪明、非常坚定的天主教徒所占据。最重要的是，正如我们在上一集中提到的，我认为
the vast majority of the population of England are instinctively, if not kind of vehemently Catholic. Yeah. So a small sea conservative, I suppose, is what they are, right? Yeah. And I think that even those who are not fervent in their loyalties either way are kind of weary of what you were saying, this kind of endless seesawing between reformation and counter-reformation, all the kind of endless process of upheavals. And adding to the problems that Elizabeth faced, if she is going to set about transforming England into a Protestant state, as basically she has to, then this has implications not just for domestic policy, but also for foreign relations. Because England is facing two continental superpowers relative to these two superpowers, Spain and France, England is very much a second rate power. And both these superpowers are, of course,
英国绝大多数人口在直觉上，如果不是激烈地，也是天主教徒。是的。所以我想他们是小写的“保守派”，对吧？是的。而且我认为即使是那些在忠诚度上并不狂热的人，也对你所说的这种在宗教改革和反宗教改革之间无休止的摇摆，以及所有这些无休止的动荡过程感到厌倦。再加上伊丽莎白面临的问题，如果她要着手将英国转变为一个新教国家，正如她基本上必须做的那样，那么这不仅对国内政策，而且对外交关系都有影响。因为英国正面临两个大陆超级大国，相对于这两个超级大国——西班牙和法国，英国在很大程度上是一个二流强国。而这两个超级大国当然都是
Catholic. And Mary Tudor, Elizabeth's elder sister, who's just died, she had been Catholic and so she had been able to ally herself to one of these superpowers, namely Spain. And this had actually been excellent for England's security because it had buttressed England's ability to defend herself against her traditional enemy, which of course is France. And if Elizabeth is going to ram through a Protestant restoration, then what are the implications of that for English security? Because if she loses Spain as an ally, then that may well leave her very exposed to French machinations. And the threat from France isn't just to England, but to Elizabeth personally. Because her claim to the throne, although the mass of people in England
天主教国家。而伊丽莎白的姐姐玛丽·都铎，也就是刚刚去世的那位，她是天主教徒，所以她能够与其中一个超级大国，即西班牙结盟。这对英国的安全实际上是非常有利的，因为它加强了英国抵御传统敌人（当然是法国）的能力。如果伊丽莎白要强行推行新教复辟，那么这对英国的安全意味着什么？因为如果她失去了西班牙这个盟友，那么她很可能会让自己完全暴露在法国的阴谋之下。而来自法国的威胁不仅针对英国，也针对伊丽莎白个人。因为她对王位的要求，尽管英国的大多数民众
accept it is not absolutely rock solid because she rules as queen by virtue of an act that her father had passed in 1544 settling the succession. And it's really important, which is why we've kind of mentioned it several times over the course of this series. It had restored first Mary and then Elizabeth to the line of succession after Edward the Sixth, if Edward the Sixth doesn't have any children which he doesn't. But it had left both Mary and Elizabeth as bastards. So there was a kind of inherent contradiction there, an inherent tension. Mary, when she becomes queen, had got Parliament to repudiate her bastardy, but she had left Elizabeth as a bastard. Now that Elizabeth is queen, is she going to do what Mary had done and have her bastardy removed? She doesn't. And I think
接受了它，但并不绝对稳固，因为她是以她父亲在1544年通过的一项确立继承权的法案为依据担任女王的。这非常重要，这也是为什么我们在本系列节目中多次提到它的原因。它在爱德华六世之后恢复了玛丽和伊丽莎白的继承顺序，如果爱德华六世没有孩子的话（他确实没有）。但它将玛丽和伊丽莎白都留在了私生女的地位上。所以这里存在一种内在的矛盾，一种内在的张力。玛丽在成为女王时，曾让议会否认了她的私生女身份，但她却让伊丽莎白保持了私生女的身份。现在伊丽莎白成了女王，她会像玛丽那样做，消除自己的私生女身份吗？她没有。我认为
the reason for that is that she knows that the entire issue is incredibly toxic. Amber Lynn is much less popular in the kind of national imagination than Catherine of Aragon had been. And And she is widely viewed as having been Henry's concubine, as having been the great whore. And the implication of that is that Elizabeth is therefore the little whore. And so she just doesn't want to kind of poke that hornet's nest. And so she leaves it alone. But the downside of that, of course, is that there are questions over her legitimacy. And therefore, there is lots of scope for the French to make mischief.
原因在于她知道整个问题极其棘手。安妮·博林在国民想象中的受欢迎程度远不如阿拉贡的凯瑟琳。而且她被广泛视为亨利的妾，被视为“大淫妇”。这意味着伊丽莎白因此就是“小淫妇”。所以她只是不想去捅那个马蜂窝。因此她对此置之不理。但这样做的负面影响当然是，她的合法性存在疑问。因此，法国人有很多制造麻烦的空间。
And what is worse, the French actually have. a possible replacement, don't they, to hand, who is Catholic, who is clearly legitimate because she's a relative of the Tudors, she's a cousin of Elizabeth, and she is very pro-French. And this is somebody that we have already covered on the rest is history at some length. That is Mary Stewart, Mary Queen of Scots, who's married to the dauphin. Remember, Tom, you described how she single-handedly steered a ship to France and the and the teeth of a gale at the age of five. And the French have started to promote her already as acclaimant to the English throne, haven't they?
更糟糕的是，法国人实际上手头有一个可能的替代者，不是吗？她是天主教徒，显然是合法的，因为她是都铎家族的亲戚，是伊丽莎白的表亲，而且非常亲法。这就是我们已经在“历史即是一切”节目中详细介绍过的人。那就是玛丽·斯图亚特，苏格兰女王玛丽，她嫁给了法国王储。还记得吗，汤姆，你描述过她如何在五岁时独自一人在狂风中驾驶一艘船前往法国。法国人已经开始宣传她是英国王位的觊觎者了，不是吗？
The French love a pretender. They love a pretender to the English throne and they've got a brilliant one in Mary Stewart. Yeah, so the moment Mary Tudor dies in the Dauphin's household where Mary is married to the Dauphin, all the crockery starts, you know, the royal coat of arms of England starts appearing. Whenever Mary Stewart enters a room, people say make way for the Queen of England. And from this point on, the story of Mary Queen of Scots is shadowing the story of Elizabeth Tudor. So anyone who hasn't listened to the series on Mary Queen of Scots, it's episode 584 continuing on from that. It's a good compliment, I think, to this series.
法国人喜欢觊觎者。他们喜欢英国王位的觊觎者，而他们在玛丽·斯图亚特身上找到了一个绝佳的人选。是的，所以当玛丽·都铎在王储家中去世时，玛丽嫁给了王储，所有的瓷器都开始……你知道，英国的皇家纹章开始出现了。每当玛丽·斯图亚特走进一个房间，人们就会说“为英格兰女王让路”。从这一点开始，苏格兰女王玛丽的故事就一直笼罩着伊丽莎白·都铎的故事。所以任何没有听过关于苏格兰女王玛丽系列节目的听众，那是第584集，从那里继续听。我认为这是对本系列节目的一个很好的补充。
And so the threats to Elizabeth as a Protestant internally and externally are absolutely immense. And there's a real kind of aura of Cold War paranoia in the early months of Elizabeth's reign. I think often people have the idea that when Elizabeth becomes queen, you know, the maypoles go up, the sunshine, it's Mary England and all that. That's not at all the environment. So as a contemporary makes clear, the atmosphere is dark with kind of tension, with menace. So he wrote every report was greedily both inquired and received, all truth suspected, diverse tales believed, many improbable conjectures hatched and nourished. It is an absolute viper's nest. But Elizabeth has come into power, hasn't she?
因此，作为新教徒的伊丽莎白在内部和外部面临的威胁是巨大的。在伊丽莎白统治的最初几个月里，有一种真正的冷战偏执气氛。我认为人们通常认为，当伊丽莎白成为女王时，五朔节花柱竖起来了，阳光明媚，那是“快乐的英格兰”等等。环境根本不是那样。正如一位同时代人所说，气氛因紧张和威胁而变得阴暗。他写道：“每一份报告都被贪婪地询问和接收，所有的真相都被怀疑，各种各样的故事被相信，许多不可能的推测被孵化和滋养。”这绝对是一个毒蛇窝。但伊丽莎白已经掌权了，不是吗？
You described last time how she has, you called it a shadow government. She has been, she has always had people around her. And some of them have been around her for a long time. So we've had a lot of Welsh history in recent episodes because of the presence of this guy, Thomas Parry. And he's back, isn't he? He becomes controller of the household. And despite being, what was he, a fat, garrulous Welshman, a self-indulgent, greedy Welshman? Fat self-satisfied Welshman.
你上次描述了她如何拥有你所说的“影子政府”。她一直有人围绕在身边。其中一些人已经陪伴她很长时间了。所以我们在最近的几集中讲了很多威尔士历史，因为这个家伙托马斯·帕里的存在。他又回来了，不是吗？他成为了家庭总管。尽管他是什么，一个肥胖、多嘴的威尔士人，一个放纵、贪婪的威尔士人？肥胖、自满的威尔士人。
Fat self-satisfied Welshman. Despite that, or perhaps because of it, he is appointed to her council. So he's done very well. And someone else who has always been very close to her, of course, is Kate Ashley, who had been her kind of nanny, her teacher, and then her confidante throughout all the kind of years of danger and peril before she became queen. She gets appointed chief gentlewoman of the Privy Chamber.
肥胖、自满的威尔士人。尽管如此，或者也许正因为如此，他被任命为她的顾问。所以他做得很好。当然，另一个一直与她非常亲近的人是凯特·阿什利，她曾是她的保姆、老师，然后在她成为女王之前的所有危险岁月里，她一直是她的知己。她被任命为枢密院首席女官。
and the privy chamber is an important part of any monarch's household. And because Elizabeth is a queen, men can't really be a part of this. So therefore, Kate actually has, you know, she wields quite a degree of influence. She's a significant player too. But the key player, the key player is the man who we basically ended the last episode with. And this is William Cecil. And she has been appointed Elizabeth's new secretary. but that title kind of barely hints at his significance
枢密院是任何君主家庭的重要组成部分。因为伊丽莎白是女王，男人不能真正参与其中。所以凯特·阿什利确实拥有相当大的影响力。她也是一个重要人物。但关键人物，关键人物是我们基本上在上一集结尾提到的那个人。这就是威廉·塞西尔。她被任命为伊丽莎白的新秘书，但这个头衔几乎没有暗示他的重要性，
because in effect he is prime minister and Dominic I think he is a very Sandbrookian character you mean that surely is there as high praise I hope you will take it as high praise because I actually think that in any ranking of the most impressive political operator in the British history so not just English but British history
因为实际上他是首相。多米尼克，我认为他是一个非常“桑德布鲁克式”的人物。你是说这肯定是一种高度赞扬，我希望你会把它当作高度赞扬，因为我实际上认为，在英国历史上任何最令人印象深刻的政治操盘手排名中，不仅仅是英格兰，而是英国历史上，
I would say he is very much at the top he's an extraordinary competent Right. I mean, more than competent. He's brilliant. Okay, it's very clear to me there's going to be some hideous sting in the tale in this comparison. But I wait to see what that's going to be. No, not at all.
我会说他绝对名列前茅。他非常能干。没错。我的意思是，不仅仅是能干。他是天才。好吧，我很清楚，这个比较中会有一些可怕的讽刺。但我等着看那会是什么。不，一点也不。
No. It's Cecil in the first days of her reign, who essentially guides Elizabeth in the selection of her council. And this council is very streamlined. Essentially, it's kind of halved. Under Mary, it becomes very cumbersome. Cecil wants a much more readily controllable body of men. By convention, there are several secretaries. Cecil's not having that. He is the only secretary. He is operating alone. And of course,
不。在伊丽莎白统治的最初几天里，正是塞西尔在本质上指导伊丽莎白挑选她的顾问。这个顾问团非常精简。本质上，它被减半了。在玛丽统治下，它变得非常繁琐。塞西尔想要一个更容易控制的机构。按照惯例，有几位秘书。塞西尔不接受这一点。他是唯一的秘书。他独自运作。当然，
this is absolutely punishing because it means that he has a lot on his plate. But that Dominic is how he likes it. So he chairs the council. He runs the royal secretariat. If there's a pie, he has his finger in it. So to quote Stephen Alford, who's written the definitive biography of Cecil, he was everywhere and everything in Elizabethan government. No piece of paper, no report, to no policy, no event or panic, or crisis at home or abroad could escape his attention. And Elizabeth had appointed him partly because he's incredibly able, partly because he's a very committed Protestant, very loyal to her, but also because he knows, but also because she knows that he is equal to the challenges of such an exhausting role. And right from the beginning, so from
这绝对是惩罚性的，因为这意味着他肩上的担子很重。但多米尼克，这就是他喜欢的。所以他主持顾问团。他管理皇家秘书处。如果有馅饼，他就会插上一手。引用斯蒂芬·阿尔福德的话，他写了塞西尔的权威传记，他在伊丽莎白的政府中无处不在，无所不能。没有一张纸、一份报告、一项政策、一个事件或恐慌，或者国内外的危机能逃过他的注意。伊丽莎白任命他，部分是因为他非常有能力，部分是因为他是一个非常坚定的新教徒，对她非常忠诚，但也因为她知道他能够胜任如此繁重角色的挑战。从一开始，也就是从
the first meeting of her council, which was held at Hatfield 10 days after her accession, She's absolutely upfront about what she expects from him. Her kind of prescription that she gives him is very famous. But I think that any leader, even today, could do worse than tell, you know, their kind of ministers or their right-hand people to echo Elizabeth's words. So she says, this judgment I have of you, that you will not be corrupted with any manner of gift and that you will be faithful to the state and that without respect of my private will, you will give me that counsel you think best. So essentially, Elizabeth is saying to Cecil, you know, speak truth to power. Even if I don't want to hear what you've got to say, I still want to hear it. I respect your opinion that much.
她顾问团的第一次会议开始，那是在她即位10天后在哈特菲尔德举行的，她就非常坦率地表达了她对他的期望。她给他的那种处方非常有名。但我认为，即使在今天，任何领导者如果能告诉他们的部长或得力助手去呼应伊丽莎白的话，也不会做得更差。所以她说：“我对你有这样的判断，你不会被任何形式的礼物所腐蚀，你会忠于国家，并且不顾我的私人意愿，你会给我你认为最好的建议。”所以本质上，伊丽莎白是在对塞西尔说：“对权力说真话。”即使我不想听你要说的话，我仍然想听。我非常尊重你的意见。
He sounds brilliant. And actually, even better, Tom, because you describe him in your notes. He was subtle and self-disciplined, but he believed to the core of his being that Elizabeth's kingdom was called by God to cast off the shackles of papist bondage. So, I mean, he's not wrong, right? well discuss certainly what's not wrong is that he he wants Elizabeth and England to embrace
他听起来很棒。而且实际上更好，汤姆，因为你在笔记中描述了他。他既微妙又自律，但他内心深处坚信，伊丽莎白的王国是上帝召唤来摆脱教皇束缚的枷锁的。所以，我的意思是，他没错，对吧？好吧，我们肯定会讨论什么不是错的，那就是他希望伊丽莎白和英格兰拥抱
what he always calls true religion which effectively is what I think we can now start to call Protestantism he wants England to be properly Protestant and he's not alone in this ambition so we talked in the previous episode how there are a lot of Protestants who've basically hunkered down under Mary's reign
他一直称之为“真宗教”的东西，这实际上就是我认为我们现在可以开始称之为“新教”的东西。他希望英格兰成为真正的新教国家，他在这方面的抱负并不孤单。所以我们在上一集中谈到，有很多新教徒在玛丽统治下基本上躲藏起来，
who've kept quiet who've played it cool and who've lived to tell the tale there are also quite a lot of Protestants, those of the hotter variety, the more vehement in their opinions, who have hot-footed it to Geneva, where John Calvin has set up a godly republic. And they, with the death of Mary and the accession of a Protestant queen, start returning to England. And their view of Elizabeth isn't always 100% complementary. So John Knox, the Scottish radical Protestant. who had gone to Geneva and had lambasted women as queens, which then makes him very unpopular with Elizabeth. But also something else that made him unpopular with Elizabeth. She basically accuses Elizabeth of having been a massive tremor. He wrote to her, for fear of your life, you did decline from God and bow in idolatry. So there's this sense that the exiles in Geneva have kept their purity, whereas, you know, people like Elizabeth and indeed Cecil have had to play
保持安静，保持低调，并活了下来。还有相当多的新教徒，那些更热烈、观点更激烈的人，他们匆忙赶往日内瓦，约翰·加尔文在那里建立了一个虔诚的共和国。随着玛丽的去世和一位新教女王的即位，他们开始回到英格兰。他们对伊丽莎白的看法并不总是100%赞赏。所以约翰·诺克斯，那位苏格兰激进的新教徒，他去了日内瓦，猛烈抨击女性作为女王，这使他在伊丽莎白那里非常不受欢迎。但也还有其他事情让他不受欢迎。她基本上指责伊丽莎白是一个巨大的“动摇者”。他写信给她：“为了你的生命安全，你背离了上帝，向偶像崇拜低头。”所以有一种感觉，日内瓦的流亡者保持了他们的纯洁，而像伊丽莎白，甚至塞西尔这样的人，不得不扮演
the hypocrite. And so when people like this come back to England, they are pretty intemperate in their demands of Elizabeth. They're saying, you know, fine, you're a Protestant, but you went to mass, you're not as good as us, basically do what we say, hand over the reins of government to us, we know what's best. And again and again, whenever I read about this, this dynamic between Elizabeth as a Protestant leader, but with kind of hot heads, if you like on her left, I think about Labour Prime Ministers who are being harassed by left-wing backbenchers to be more radical. Yeah, and this is something that's going to endure and run and run in English history, isn't it? So these people are basically the ancestors of the Puritans.
伪君子。所以当这样的人回到英格兰时，他们对伊丽莎白的要求非常不节制。他们说：“好吧，你是新教徒，但你参加了弥撒，你不如我们，基本上听我们的，把政府的缰绳交给我们，我们知道什么是最好的。”而且每当我读到这个，伊丽莎白作为新教领袖，但左翼有那种“热血分子”的动态时，我就会想到工党首相被左翼后座议员骚扰要求更激进。是的，这是英国历史上将持续存在并不断上演的事情，不是吗？所以这些人基本上是清教徒的祖先。
They are more extreme and they suspect the court of trimming and of basically being only half-heartedly committed to the Protestant cause. And Elizabeth, I guess she would say, I'm not Kirstama, I'm not a Labour Prime Minister. what makes me different is I don't answer to you. You know, I am the queen. I am the daughter of Heming the 8th. I am the head of the church. I answer to God. I know best.
他们更极端，他们怀疑宫廷在“修剪”，基本上只是半心半意地致力于新教事业。而伊丽莎白，我想她会说：“我不是斯塔默，我不是工党首相。我与众不同的是我不对你们负责。你知道，我是女王。我是亨利八世的女儿。我是教会的首脑。我对上帝负责。我知道什么是最好的。”
And you basically pipe down and, you know, you knuckle under and do what I tell you, right? Yeah. So she's got all these people coming back and telling her what she must do. You don't say must to a queen. That's unacceptable. And it's really telling, I think, that she loathes, clerical. essentially. She's the first monarch not to have any clerics, any clergyman on her council. She really, really dislikes them. But I think her contempt for all these kind of Protestant radicals
“你们基本上闭嘴，低头做我告诉你们的事，对吧？”是的。所以她有所有这些人回来告诉她她必须做什么。你不能对女王说“必须”。那是不可接受的。我认为非常能说明问题的是，她本质上厌恶教士。她是第一位顾问团中没有任何教士的君主。她真的非常非常不喜欢他们。但我认为她对所有这些回到英格兰并向她“说教”如何成为女王的新教激进分子的蔑视，
coming back and mansplaining to her how she should be a queen. It's not just a kind of a political distaste for them. It's also because she's smarter than them. She's got her finger more on the pulse. She's more alert to the currents of politics. And of course, she wants a Protestant in England, not at the cost of her throne. And all the time while she has been kind of in the cockpit of political power, she has been learning lessons from her predecessors. So from her brother, Edward VI, she has learned, don't push things too hard. Don't alienate people by rushing things. So to quote Lucy Wooding in Tudor England, it could be argued that Elizabeth wanted stability as much as she wanted Protestantism. And so the question there is, you know, is her policy on
不仅仅是一种政治上的厌恶。这也是因为她比他们更聪明。她对脉搏的把握更准。她对政治潮流更警觉。当然，她想要一个新教的英格兰，而不是以牺牲她的王位为代价。在她在政治权力的驾驶舱里的时候，她一直在向她的前任学习。所以从她的兄弟爱德华六世那里，她学到了：不要把事情推得太紧。不要通过仓促行事来疏远人们。所以引用露西·伍丁在《都铎王朝的英格兰》中的话，可以说伊丽莎白想要稳定，就像她想要新教一样。所以问题在于，她的宗教政策，
religion, is it being dictated primarily by her spiritual convictions or by her sense of what was possible politically? And Wooding actually argues there's no real contradiction there. So to quote her, for a woman who understood that she had been appointed by God to protect her realm from divisional conquest, while at the same time promoting the true faith, it is likely that there was no separation between these two motivations. That's surely the key to it. We're great politicians, and she is a great politician, arguably the greatest in England's history. They see no difference between the demands of political pragmatism and the dictates the political principle, do they? They come to say, well, what I can do, actually, you know what? Coincidentally,
是主要由她的精神信念决定的，还是由她对政治上可能性的感觉决定的？伍丁实际上认为这两者之间没有真正的矛盾。所以引用她的话：“对于一个明白自己是被上帝任命来保护她的王国免受分裂征服，同时又在促进真信仰的女性来说，这两种动机之间很可能没有分离。”这肯定就是关键所在。伟大的政治家，而她是一位伟大的政治家，可以说是英国历史上最伟大的，他们认为政治实用主义的要求和政治原则的指令之间没有区别，不是吗？他们会说：“好吧，我能做的，实际上，你知道吗？巧合的是，
it turns out to be the right thing to do. Yeah. And I think that's exactly how she perceives it. Maybe there's a degree of self-delusion in that, you know, as in, but I think you tend to believe your own agenda, don't you? And she is brilliant at judging just how far she can push the English people without them breaking. And indeed Parliament, because she's, you know, She wants Parliament with all the Catholic bishops inside it to vote to repudiate the papal supremacy and restore the royal supremacy. In other words, she wants to leave the Catholic hierarchy in no doubt that this is the will of the English people. Mary, when she had reversed the royal supremacy, had made sure to get rid of the Protestant bishops. Elizabeth doesn't do that. She doesn't
它竟然是正确的事情。”是的，我认为她就是这样看待它的。也许其中有一定程度的自我欺骗，你知道，但我认为你倾向于相信你自己的议程，不是吗？而且她非常擅长判断她能把英国人民推到多远而不让他们崩溃。当然还有议会，因为她，你知道，她想要议会中所有天主教主教投票否认教皇的至高无上地位并恢复皇家至高无上地位。换句话说，她想让天主教等级制度毫无疑问地知道这是英国人民的意愿。玛丽在推翻皇家至高无上地位时，确保除掉了新教主教。伊丽莎白没有那样做。她没有
kind of clear parliament out of the bishops. She wants everybody to be complicit in the decision that Parliament reaches. And so it's, you know, that's a massive risk because it could easily have exploded in her face. And in the event, this kind of revolution is forced to parliament by the absolute skin of its teeth. And it's chiefly thanks to Cecil's genius for kind of whipping and arm twisting that MPs and then the House of Lords do vote for the religious settlement. And this settlement is sometimes described as kind of centrist as being a compromise between Catholic and Protestant, but it isn't because by this point, definitely a point has been reached where it's either or you either have the papal supremacy or the
把主教们从议会中清理出去。她希望每个人都参与到议会达成的决定中。所以，你知道，这是一个巨大的风险，因为它很容易在她脸上爆炸。结果，这种革命是靠着绝对的千钧一发才在议会中通过的。这主要归功于塞西尔在“鞭策”和施压方面的天才，使得议员们，然后是上议院投票支持宗教和解。这种和解有时被描述为一种中间派，是天主教和新教之间的妥协，但事实并非如此，因为到这一点，绝对已经到了一个要么要么的时刻，你要么拥有教皇的至高无上地位，要么拥有
royal supremacy. And by voting for the royal supremacy, Parliament is voting for a church that is unmistakably Protestant. Elizabeth, unlike her father, does not call herself the supreme head of the Church of England. That's reserved for Christ. But she does call herself the supreme governor. And accepting Elizabeth as the supreme governor of the Church of England is now established as the absolute litmus test for loyalty. Everyone in government, everyone in the council, everyone in the church, everyone in parliament has to swear it. And because the Catholic bishops can't do that, effectively they are committing a kind of mass letter of resignation. They leave en masse. So that clears Catholics out of the upper echelons of the church. At the same time, a second act is passed
皇家至高无上地位。通过投票支持皇家至高无上地位，议会是在投票支持一个毫无疑问是新教的教会。伊丽莎白与她父亲不同，她不称自己为英格兰教会的“最高首脑”。那是留给基督的。但她确实称自己为“最高管理者”。接受伊丽莎白作为英格兰教会的最高管理者现在被确立为忠诚的绝对试金石。政府中的每个人、顾问团中的每个人、教会中的每个人、议会中的每个人都必须宣誓。因为天主教主教做不到这一点，他们实际上是在进行一种集体辞职。他们集体离开了。这清除了教会高层中的天主教徒。与此同时，通过了第二项法案，
imposing uniformity, which basically is prescribing doctrine. So this gets rid of lots of kind of Catholic aspects of religion, so prayers for the dead, veneration of saints, pilgrimage, rosaries, images in churches, all that kind of thing. And it also affirms the primacy of scripture, which is very Protestant. There's an evangelical prayer book, kind of based on a prayer book that had been written by Kranmer, Elizabeth's Godfather, and there's a liturgy in English. And this may sound to people who have no interest in religion who couldn't care less about the Church of England as something that's kind of peripheral and irrelevant. It absolutely is not, because by establishing this, Elizabeth is establishing the fundamentally
强制统一，这基本上是规定教义。所以这去掉了许多天主教的宗教方面，比如为死者祈祷、崇拜圣徒、朝圣、念珠、教堂里的图像，所有这些东西。它还肯定了圣经的首要地位，这是非常新教的。有一本福音派祈祷书，基于伊丽莎白的教父克兰默编写的祈祷书，并且有英语礼拜仪式。对于那些对宗教毫无兴趣、对英格兰教会毫不在意的人来说，这听起来可能有些边缘和无关紧要。它绝对不是，因为通过建立这一点，伊丽莎白正在建立英格兰作为政体的根本
Protestant character of England as a polity. And this, of course, will have a massive influence, not just on English and British politics, but on global politics, because from this moment stems the fundamentally Protestant character, for instance, of the United States of America. So, Tom, you say, you know, this is often seen as a compromise and it's not, and it's not centriism and all of this. And I completely take with your point, because you're basically saying she's pinned her colours to the mast, England now will be a Protestant country. That said, there are lots of people, well, maybe not lots, but there are certainly some people
新教特征。当然，这将产生巨大的影响，不仅对英国和英国政治，而且对全球政治，因为从这一刻起，产生了例如美利坚合众国根本上的新教特征。所以，汤姆，你说，你知道，这通常被视为一种妥协，但它不是，它不是中间主义等等。我完全同意你的观点，因为你基本上是在说她已经表明了立场，英格兰现在将是一个新教国家。话虽如此，有很多人，好吧，也许不是很多人，但肯定有一些人
who do think it's a compromise, and there are aspects. in which Elizabeth does not go as far as she could have done. And isn't that the key to her success, is that actually this point about judging how far you can push things, there are elements of what we would perceive as Catholic religion that she retains that other Protestant policies don't. For example, we have choirs. Priests dress up in fancy dress.
认为这是一种妥协，而且在某些方面，伊丽莎白并没有走得像她本可以走得那么远。这难道不是她成功的关键吗？实际上，关于判断你能把事情推到多远的这一点，她保留了我们认为属于天主教宗教的元素，而其他新教政策却没有。例如，我们有唱诗班。牧师穿着花哨的衣服。
Fancy dress. I think vestments is the word you're groping for. No, I mean, I'm very aware of the word vestments, but I'm saying it with a degree of, with a degree of, I wouldn't say scorn. Russet-coated skepticism. Exactly. Thank you.
花哨的衣服。我想“法衣”是你正在寻找的词。不，我的意思是，我非常清楚“法衣”这个词，但我说它带有一种，带有一种，我不会说是蔑视。红褐色涂层的怀疑论。没错。谢谢。
That's exactly it. To other Protestants, England does not look like a revolutionary Protestant state because it's only gone some way down that road, right? So I think, you know, choirs and altars and vestments and stuff, it's the sugar that helps the medicine go down for those who are skeptical of Protestantism. You know, there are echoes of the old order still preserved. If you're a bloke in a village who doesn't know much about this, right, and is baffled by it all, you might look on this and say, they've gone back to Protestantism, but thank God they haven't gone full kind of whitewash, scrap eulters, all of that kind of thing.
就是这样。对其他新教徒来说，英格兰看起来不像一个革命性的新教国家，因为它只是在通往那条道路上走了一段距离，对吧？所以我认为，你知道，唱诗班、祭坛、法衣之类的东西，是帮助那些对新教持怀疑态度的人接受药物的糖衣。你知道，旧秩序的回声仍然被保留着。如果你是一个村里的普通人，对这些了解不多，对这一切感到困惑，你可能会看着这些说：“他们回到了新教，但感谢上帝，他们没有完全进行那种‘粉刷’、拆除祭坛之类的东西。”
These people can still dress up and kind of sing songs. Yes, and I think this is motivated partly by pragmatism. Elizabeth, you know, said he's learned the lesson from her brother's regime. don't rush things, don't alienate people needlessly. I think it also reflects her personal convictions because Elizabeth's religious tastes were shaped by her upbringing at the court of Henry VIII and in the household of Catherine Parr
这些人仍然可以打扮起来，唱唱歌。是的，我认为这部分是出于实用主义的动机。伊丽莎白，你知道，从她兄弟的政权中吸取了教训：不要操之过急，不要无谓地疏远人们。我认为这也反映了她个人的信念，因为伊丽莎白的宗教品味是由她在亨利八世宫廷和凯瑟琳·帕尔家庭中的成长所塑造的，
and they belong to a generation where you can basically have the royal supremacy but you can also have altars and choirs and that's what she likes. I mean, Henry VIII's thing, he was a pick and mix man. He liked dishing the papal supremacy, but actually deep down he was a kind of small
他们属于这样一代人，你可以基本上拥有皇家至高无上地位，但你也可以拥有祭坛和唱诗班，这就是她喜欢的。我的意思是，亨利八世那套，他是一个“混合搭配”的人。他喜欢打击教皇的至高无上地位，但实际上在内心深处，他是一个小写的
see conservative when it came to the content of the services and the liturgy and the theology. I mean, Elizabeth is properly an evangelical. She's properly a reformed Christian, but she likes a crucifix. She loves a choir and a crucifix. And why shouldn't she have it? It's because it makes political sense, but also she's the queen. God has appointed her queen. Therefore, obviously, God likes crucifixes as well. So she's going to keep them. I think surely everybody listened to this will conclude, A, Elizabeth was right, B, the Church of England as it used to be was brilliant. And see the radicals, the evangelicals, they're a bit bonkers, aren't they? I mean, they don't see it this way.
保守派，当涉及到礼拜内容、礼仪和神学时。我的意思是，伊丽莎白是一位真正的福音派信徒。她是一位真正的改革宗基督徒，但她喜欢十字架。她热爱唱诗班和十字架。为什么她不能拥有它呢？这是因为它在政治上是有意义的，而且她是女王。上帝任命她为女王。因此，显然，上帝也喜欢十字架。所以她会保留它们。我想肯定每个听这个节目的人都会得出结论：A，伊丽莎白是对的；B，英格兰教会曾经的样子很棒；C，激进分子，福音派，他们有点疯，不是吗？我的意思是，他们不这么看。
So they think there's too much Catholicism, too much trimming, and this is really the root of the Puritan distrust of the monarchy and the central establishment that will, of course, reach its climax in the 1640s. So it's kind of like Labour MPs on the left sneering at Stama for giving messages in front of a union jack. It is exactly that. He's a fascist. yes and it has to be said that just as you know labor prime ministers tend to store up trouble for themselves with their left wing back benches so Elizabeth is also storing up trouble for herself by you know keeping the vestments and and keeping the altars because she has a problem with the fact that all the Catholic bishops have resigned on mass how is she going to fill the vacancies her preference obviously is for Protestants who like her had stayed in England and haven't gone off to Geneva and learned all kinds of mad ideas at the feet of John Calvin.
所以他们认为天主教太多了，修剪太多了，这实际上是清教徒对君主制和中央建制派不信任的根源，这种不信任当然会在17世纪40年代达到高潮。所以这有点像工党议员在左翼嘲笑斯塔默在英国国旗前发表讲话。确实就是这样。他是法西斯。是的，必须说，正如你知道工党首相倾向于因为他们的左翼后座议员而为自己储备麻烦一样，伊丽莎白也因为保留法衣和祭坛而为自己储备麻烦，因为她面临一个问题，即所有的天主教主教都集体辞职了。她将如何填补空缺？她的偏好显然是那些像她一样留在英格兰，没有去日内瓦并在约翰·加尔文脚下学到各种疯狂想法的新教徒。
And so to the degree that she can appoint such figures as bishops, she does so. And the key appointment is to the Archbishop of Canterbury, the preeminent bishop in the Church of England. And she gives that role to Matthew Parker, who was her mother's old chaplain. People may remember from our very first episode, it's to Matthew Parker that Ambelin, in her last interview with him, says, please look after my daughter, which Matthew Parker had then done over the course of Elizabeth's childhood and youth. And so you can see why he would be an obvious candidate for her. But the problem is, is that there aren't really enough people of good calibre to fill all the vacancies. And so Elizabeth ends up having to appoint eight of these kind of exiles as
因此，只要她能任命主教，她就会去做。而最关键的任命是坎特伯雷大主教，他是英格兰教会中地位最高的主教。她将这个职位授予了马修·帕克，他曾是她母亲的老牧师。大家可能还记得我们在第一集中提到的，安妮·博林在最后一次与马修·帕克交谈时，曾恳求他照顾她的女儿，而马修·帕克在伊丽莎白的童年和青年时期确实做到了这一点。所以你可以看出为什么他会是她心目中的不二人选。但问题在于，并没有足够多才华横溢的人来填补所有的空缺。因此，伊丽莎白最终不得不任命八位这类流亡者担任
bishops. And they are going to embroil her in endless rouse about vestments and crucifixes. And Elizabeth hates this. You know, she takes her God-appointed role as Supreme Governor very, very seriously. And she's not going to surrender her prerogatives to a bunch of, you know, kind of lefty theologians from Geneva. No way. Equally, as you said, the radicals see the Elizabethan Church as being kind of sunk in papist mummery. And this is a story that will run and run through Elizabeth's reign into the, you know, time of James I and then, of course, Charles I, with ultimately explosive consequences.
主教。他们会让她陷入关于法衣和十字架的无休止争吵中。伊丽莎白对此深恶痛绝。你知道，她非常非常认真地对待自己作为最高统治者的神授角色。她绝不会把自己的特权拱手让给一群来自日内瓦的左翼神学家。绝不可能。同样，正如你所说，激进派认为伊丽莎白时代的教会沉浸在天主教的繁文缛节中。这个故事将贯穿伊丽莎白的整个统治时期，一直延续到詹姆斯一世，当然还有后来的查理一世时期，并最终产生爆炸性的后果。
What about Catholics, though? There's a lot of Catholics, right? What do they think of this? And this is the other thing, which when people talk about Elizabeth's arguments with the more radical Protestants, they tend to ignore the fact that they are just little gnats to Elizabeth. They're kind of little buzzing insects. The huge threat to her is the vast mass of the English population who are Catholic. And they are Elizabeth's real. nightmare because there are just so many of them. And added to that is the fact, of course, that most of the great powers on the continent of Europe are Catholic as well. And to them, you know, a Protestant England is bound to seem a rogue state. And the risk remains that
那么天主教徒呢？有很多天主教徒，对吧？他们对此怎么看？这是另一回事，当人们谈论伊丽莎白与更激进的新教徒之间的争论时，他们往往忽略了一个事实，即对伊丽莎白来说，这些人只是小小的蚊虫。他们就像嗡嗡作响的小昆虫。对她而言，巨大的威胁是英格兰人口中占绝大多数的天主教徒。他们才是伊丽莎白真正的噩梦，因为他们的人数实在太多了。此外，当然还有一个事实，即欧洲大陆上的大多数大国也都是天主教国家。对他们来说，一个新教的英格兰注定看起来像是一个流氓国家。而风险依然存在，即
they will try and overthrow Elizabeth and replace her with a Catholic monarch. And how you head these threats off during the first year of Elizabeth's reign is the most pressing challenge that she faces, and it's the one over which she and Cecil, her first minister, are most bitterly divided, because at its heart are two massively glaring questions, which go to the very core of Elizabeth status as a queen. And the first of these is, should Elizabeth get married? And the second, which is tied in with the first question, should she appoint a successor? and there are questions on which Elizabeth and Cecil have very different points of view and Cecil finds to his fury that Elizabeth is almost impossible to pin down on them.
他们会试图推翻伊丽莎白，并用一位天主教君主取而代之。如何在伊丽莎白统治的第一年化解这些威胁，是她面临的最紧迫的挑战，也是她与她的首席大臣塞西尔产生最激烈分歧的问题，因为其核心是两个极其尖锐的问题，直接触及伊丽莎白作为女王地位的本质。第一个是，伊丽莎白应该结婚吗？第二个，与第一个问题紧密相关，她应该指定继承人吗？这些问题上，伊丽莎白和塞西尔有着非常不同的观点，塞西尔愤怒地发现，伊丽莎白几乎不可能在这些问题上做出明确表态。
But can he pin her down? What a cliffhanger we will find out after the break. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes. times, and Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered, it's showing up no matter what. Like for your long distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up. Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. In the end, this shall be for me sufficient, that a marble stone shall declare that a queen,
但他能让她表态吗？真是个悬念，休息之后我们再揭晓。本集由Uber赞助播出。你知道那种在最需要的时候有人为你挺身而出的感觉吗？我们有时都需要这种支持，而Uber深知这一点。Uber不仅仅是提供乘车或送餐服务，它意味着无论发生什么都会为你提供支持。就像为你远方的朋友，在他们生病时送去热汤，在他们情绪低落时送去鲜花。当真正重要的时候，无论是什么，你都会挺身而出。有志者，事竟成，我们正在路上。Uber，我们在路上。立即下载应用程序。最终，对我来说这就足够了，一块大理石碑将宣告一位女王，
having reigned such a time, lived and died a virgin. So that was Elizabeth I, and she was answering a House of Commons petition in early 1559, and the MPs had taken a break from arguing about religious fancy dress to press an issue on which all of them could agree, which is basically they said, come on, you need to get married because you need to have an heir. Ideally, we'd love a couple of sons and then the dynasty can endure. And this is an issue, Tom, that runs right through Elizabeth I'm the first reign. It's one of the things that we know about her. Most people even if they don't know much about Elizabeth I first know that she was the virgin queen, married to her
在位如此之久，生为处女，死亦处女。这就是伊丽莎白一世，她在1559年初回应下议院的请愿时这样说道。议员们暂停了关于宗教服饰的争论，转而提出一个他们都能达成共识的问题，基本上他们说，拜托，你需要结婚，因为你需要有继承人。理想情况下，我们想要几个儿子，这样王朝才能延续。汤姆，这是一个贯穿伊丽莎白一世整个统治时期的问题。这是我们了解她的事情之一。大多数人即使对伊丽莎白一世了解不多，也知道她是“童贞女王”，嫁给了她的
kingdom. And actually, if Parliament had had its way, this would never have been the case because again and again, 1563, 66, 1576, they petition her and say, Will you please get married? Will you please have a husband and then have children? And obviously the urgency is because, well, it's multiple things. To some degree, I suppose it's about sexism, isn't it? I think probably not much. I mean, there's a shade perhaps of that,
王国。实际上，如果议会能如愿以偿，情况就不会是这样了，因为他们一次又一次地（1563年、1566年、1576年）向她请愿，说：你愿意结婚吗？你愿意找个丈夫然后生孩子吗？显然，这种紧迫感是因为，嗯，有很多原因。在某种程度上，我想这与性别歧视有关，不是吗？我想可能没那么多。我的意思是，也许有一点点，
that they think that power is properly the dimension of men and that therefore Elizabeth would be better off with a man by her side. I don't actually think that's a really salient fact. Do you think the dynasty and civil war? is the single biggest thing. That thing that is basically, you don't understand the Tudors if you don't get that all through the decades of the Tudor dynasty, people are thinking this is a dynasty of Parvenus and they're going to fall any moment and then there'll be, it'll be Wars of the Roses round two, basically. Sure. But for, say, Cecil, you know,
他们认为权力理应属于男性，因此伊丽莎白如果身边有个男人会更好。我其实不认为这是一个非常突出的事实。你认为王朝和内战是最大的问题吗？基本上，如果你不明白都铎王朝几十年来人们都在想“这是一个暴发户王朝，随时可能倒台，然后基本上会重演玫瑰战争”，你就无法理解都铎王朝。当然。但是对于塞西尔来说，你知道，
an ardent Protestant, there's now an added dimension as well, which is that if the Protestant reformation is dependent on the life of Elizabeth, just as the Catholic Reformation had been dependent on the life of Mary, then it's absolutely crucial that the succession is sorted out. And the best way to do that is for Elizabeth to have a son. And then the succession is clear. And as Cecil is all too painfully aware, the obvious successor is the most nightmarish successor imaginable
作为一个狂热的新教徒，现在又增加了一个维度，那就是如果新教改革依赖于伊丽莎白的生命，就像天主教改革依赖于玛丽的生命一样，那么解决继承权问题就绝对至关重要。而最好的办法就是让伊丽莎白生个儿子。这样继承权就明确了。正如塞西尔痛苦地意识到的那样，最明显的继承人是任何坚定的英格兰新教徒所能想象到的最可怕的继承人，
if you are a stalwart English Protestant, because that successor potentially is Mary Queen of Scots. Yeah. She's not just Catholic, but also from July 1559, she's become the Queen of France. So the Dauphin, her husband, succeeded his father. I mean, it's a double nightmare. She has so many negatives. She's Catholic. She's Scottish. She's kind of French and she's also useless. But apart from that, she's brilliant. So no wonder that Cecil is saying to Elizabeth, come on, it's your patriotic duty. Get married. Give us a son. So he, you know, he's again and again, he's kind of writing this to all his mates, moaning about Elizabeth's refusal to do this. God send our mistress a husband and buy him a son that we may hope our posterity shall have a masculine succession. And Elizabeth, when she gets messages like this, so actually that petition that she gets from the House of Commons, she's not saying that she's going to stay a virgin queen, but she's saying this might be one option.
因为那个继承人很可能是苏格兰女王玛丽。是的。她不仅是天主教徒，而且从1559年7月起，她还成为了法国王后。所以她的丈夫王储继承了他父亲的王位。我的意思是，这是双重噩梦。她有太多的负面因素。她是天主教徒。她是苏格兰人。她有点像法国人，而且她也没什么用。但除此之外，她很出色。所以难怪塞西尔对伊丽莎白说，拜托，这是你的爱国义务。结婚吧。给我们生个儿子。所以他，你知道，他一次又一次地给他的所有伙伴写信，抱怨伊丽莎白拒绝这样做。上帝赐予我们的女主人一位丈夫，并赐予他一个儿子，这样我们就可以希望我们的后代拥有男性继承人。而伊丽莎白在收到这样的信息时，实际上她从下议院收到的那份请愿书，她并没有说她要保持童贞女王的身份，但她是在说这可能是一个选择。
She does leave the door open. She's never, you know, she never says never, but in a way she is because it turns out that all these, well, I'm going to think about it. Effectively, she's just kind of kicking the whole issue. down the road, she does not want to commit. So people may wonder, well, why does she not want to commit? And I think there are all kinds of potential answers to that question, some of which perhaps are rooted in her upbringing, you know, which we've been tracking. You can see that perhaps there's a kind of an association of marriage with death, you know, the execution of her mother.
她确实留有余地。她从来没有，你知道，她从不说绝不，但在某种程度上她确实是这样，因为事实证明所有这些“嗯，我会考虑的”说法。实际上，她只是在把整个问题拖延下去，她不想做出承诺。所以人们可能会想，为什么她不想做出承诺？我认为对这个问题有各种各样的潜在答案，其中一些可能植根于她的成长经历，你知道，我们一直在追踪。你可以看出，也许婚姻与死亡之间存在某种联系，你知道，她母亲的处决。
I must surely have kind of weighed on her. And she did once confide that she had, hated the idea of marriage every day more for reasons which she could not divulge to a twin soul if she had one, much less to a living creature, which does suggest that perhaps there are kind of buried psychological reasons. But we can't be sure about that because, as we've said, Elizabeth is a very close person. Her emotions are kept very, very private. So I think you're kind of going into the dimension of psychological speculation there. But there is another much more obvious reason why she refuses to be pinned down. And that is that as she recognizes much more clearly than Cecil, her unmarried state constitutes an absolutely brilliant diplomatic weapon
一定在某种程度上压在她心头。她确实曾经吐露过，她每天都越来越讨厌婚姻的想法，原因她无法向灵魂伴侣（如果她有的话）透露，更不用说向活人透露了，这确实表明也许存在某种深埋的心理原因。但我们不能确定，因为正如我们所说，伊丽莎白是一个非常内向的人。她的情绪被保护得非常非常私密。所以我认为你在那里进入了心理推测的维度。但她拒绝做出明确表态还有另一个更明显的原因。那就是，正如她比塞西尔更清楚地认识到的那样，她未婚的状态构成了一种绝对出色的外交武器，
because she is a queen of England and therefore her hand in marriage is an amazing prize for any Christian prince. And so Elizabeth likes to keep the prospect dangling in front of would-be suitors. And this works brilliantly in two ways, because firstly, every time there's an inquiry from a continental suitor about, you know, could I marry you, that inquiry serves to validate her legitimacy. But what it also does, it enables Elizabeth to bring in her favorite strategy, which is essentially to string people along, to say, oh, I might give you this, and then never giving it to them. And actually, she does it brilliantly because she is a kind of consummate politician. An example of this, of how she pursues this strategy of dangling the
因为她是英格兰女王，所以她的婚姻是一份给任何基督教君主的惊人奖赏。因此，伊丽莎白喜欢让这种前景在追求者面前悬而未决。这在两个方面发挥了极好的作用，因为首先，每当有来自欧洲大陆的追求者询问“我能娶你吗”时，这种询问都有助于验证她的合法性。但它也使伊丽莎白能够运用她最喜欢的策略，即本质上是吊着人们的胃口，说“哦，我可能会给你这个”，然后却从不给他们。实际上，她做得非常出色，因为她是一位完美的政治家。关于她如何追求这种在人们面前悬挂婚姻前景的策略的一个例子，
prospect of marriage in front of people, is demonstrated by her relationship with Philip of Spain, her erstwhile brother-in-law, so the husband of her dead sister, Mary. And to Philip, his marriage to Mary had mattered because England mattered. It was, you know, England's a second-rate power, but is a very, very useful counterpoint to France. And so the moment Mary is dead, Philip basically turns through Elizabeth and say, well, you know, let's, what about it? Let's do it. You know, it would be a kind of Catherine of Aragon in reverse. Elizabeth very politely turns him down and Philip then starts proposing a kind of number of other matches for her. All of them are calculated to seal the friendship between the Habsburgs and England. And she's saying, yeah, well, maybe perhaps
体现在她与西班牙的菲利普的关系上，也就是她已故的姐夫，她死去的姐姐玛丽的丈夫。对菲利普来说，他与玛丽的婚姻很重要，因为英格兰很重要。你知道，英格兰是一个二流强国，但它是法国的一个非常非常有用的制衡点。所以玛丽一死，菲利普基本上就转向伊丽莎白说，好吧，你知道，怎么样？我们结婚吧。你知道，这会是一种反向的阿拉贡的凯瑟琳。伊丽莎白非常有礼貌地拒绝了他，菲利普随后开始为她提议其他一些婚配。所有这些都是为了巩固哈布斯堡王朝与英格兰之间的友谊。而她说，是的，嗯，也许吧，
kind of prevaricating, playing coy, never committing. And the result of all this, Elizabeth dangling the prospect of marriage, dangling the prospect of an English alliance with Spain against France, is that Philip effectively, for years, plays the role of Elizabeth's defender in Catholic Europe. He refuses to sanction a crusade against her. He leans on the Pope, not to excommunicate her. And this, I think, may seem very counterintuitive to people who know Philip as the man who sends the Spanish Armada, to overthrow Elizabeth. But actually, in the early years of Elizabeth's reign, he is her great defender. He's absolutely not her inveterate enemy. And that is a reflection of Elizabeth's diplomatic skill, essentially, in kind of playing him like a fiddle. So you've got the staying single as a kind of diplomatic maneuver, and she's brilliant
有点推诿，装模作样，从不做出承诺。所有这一切的结果，伊丽莎白悬挂着婚姻的前景，悬挂着英格兰与西班牙结盟对抗法国的前景，使得菲利普实际上多年来在天主教欧洲扮演了伊丽莎白捍卫者的角色。他拒绝批准对她进行十字军东征。他向教皇施压，不要将她逐出教会。我认为，对于那些知道菲利普是派遣西班牙无敌舰队去推翻伊丽莎白的人来说，这似乎非常违反直觉。但实际上，在伊丽莎白统治的早期，他是她伟大的捍卫者。他绝对不是她根深蒂固的敌人。这反映了伊丽莎白的外交技巧，本质上是像拉小提琴一样操纵他。所以你拥有保持单身作为一种外交手段，而她非常擅长这样做，
at doing that, partly because it's in her nature. She's brilliant at prevarication as a political ploy, at keeping her true intention and secret playing her cards close to her chess very cleverly and so on. And I think also psychologically, she hates commitment. Well, I mean, this goes to surely what is the single most important reason why she doesn't marry. The moment that she marries, she loses an enormous amount of her power and her agency. So as soon as a foreign spouse arrives with his own courtiers, with his own cronies, He becomes the focus of the court.
部分原因是这符合她的天性。她非常擅长将推诿作为一种政治策略，将她的真实意图隐藏起来，非常聪明地不露声色等等。而且我认为在心理上，她也讨厌承诺。嗯，我的意思是，这肯定触及了她不结婚的最重要原因。一旦她结婚，她就会失去大量的权力和自主权。所以一旦一位外国配偶带着他自己的朝臣、他自己的亲信到来，他就会成为宫廷的焦点。
You know, he becomes king, possibly. Lots of people look to him to make decisions and so on. And surely, I mean, it's amazing that actually Cecil never quite gets this, right? Maybe because he's a man and it doesn't occur to him, you know, that she will lose so much as soon as she makes that decision. I think every, they all assume that a queen has to marry, that she has to make, that it's her duty. I think it basically doesn't kind of cross their minds. that she might not. There are any very few people who kind of penetrate to what seems to us an obvious state of affairs. And perhaps it's telling that one of them was, was not English,
你知道，他可能会成为国王。很多人指望他做决定等等。而且肯定，我的意思是，令人惊讶的是，塞西尔实际上从未完全明白这一点，对吧？也许因为他是个男人，他没想到她一旦做出那个决定就会失去那么多。我认为每个人，他们都认为女王必须结婚，她必须做出决定，这是她的职责。我认为这基本上没有闪过他们的脑海，她可能不会结婚。很少有人能看透在我们看来显而易见的事实。也许说明问题的是，其中一个人不是英格兰人，
but a Scottish ambassador to her court. So James Melville, he was called. And he kind of goes straight, you know, he immediately sees what Elizabeth's up to and wrote to her, Your Majesty thinks if you were married, you would be but Queen of England. And now you are both King and Queen, I know your spirit cannot endure a commander. And he's absolutely right. I think. think. So she's playing two roles right now. She's both the queen and the king, and she'll lose the role of the king. Of course, the tragedy for Elizabeth, though, is that by preserving her own power and agency, she is effectively signing her dynasty's death warrant. Because the moment, you know, by not marrying and having an heir, she is basically saying, well, I will preserve my own
而是她宫廷里的一位苏格兰大使。所以他叫詹姆斯·梅尔维尔。他直接，你知道，他立刻看出了伊丽莎白的意图，并写信给她：“陛下认为如果您结婚了，您就只是英格兰女王了。而现在您既是国王又是女王，我知道您的精神无法忍受一位指挥官。”他是绝对正确的。我想。所以她现在扮演着两个角色。她既是女王又是国王，而她会失去国王的角色。当然，对伊丽莎白来说，悲剧在于，通过维护自己的权力和自主权，她实际上是在签署她王朝的死亡判决书。因为那一刻，你知道，通过不结婚和生下继承人，她基本上是在说，好吧，我会保留我自己的
agency, but the cost is the Tudors end with me. Yeah. And that then leaves open the question of who would succeed her. You know, if the Tudor dynasty goes extinct, then who is going to be the next king or indeed queen? Because, of course, the major threat, as it's always been, is Mary Queen of Scots. And, you know, she's legitimate. She's Catholic. She's Queen of France. All these things we've been listing. These make her an incredible menace in the early years of Elizabeth's reign. And it's Cecil's job as Elizabeth's chief minister. If Elizabeth won't marry, then to take alternative steps to guard against what Cecil sees as the ultimate threat of Mary Queen of Scots succeeding her. And the key, Cecil recognizes very clearly, is to disrupt the alliance
自主权，但代价是都铎王朝在我这里终结。是的。这随后留下了一个问题，即谁将继承她。你知道，如果都铎王朝灭绝了，那么谁将成为下一任国王，甚至是女王？因为，当然，主要的威胁，正如一直以来的那样，是苏格兰女王玛丽。而且，你知道，她是合法的。她是天主教徒。她是法国王后。所有我们列出的这些事情。这些使她在伊丽莎白统治的早期成为一个令人难以置信的威胁。而作为伊丽莎白首席大臣，塞西尔的工作是，如果伊丽莎白不结婚，那么就采取替代措施来防范塞西尔所认为的苏格兰女王玛丽继承她的终极威胁。而关键点，塞西尔非常清楚地认识到，是破坏联盟
between France and Scotland, of which Mary's marriage to the King of France is the kind of the great symbol, the old alliance, as it's called. And so he says, well, what if I can replace the alliance between Scotland and France with an alliance between Scotland and England? And this might seem a huge challenge because Scotland and England have been, you know, ancestral enemies for generations and generations, but he doesn't see it as impossible. He does what he always does when he's faced with a huge challenge, which is to kind of essentially draw up a memo and kind of lay out all the arguments in bullet point form. And so he writes, it must necessarily be provided that Scotland be not so subject to the appointments of France as it is presently, which being an ancient
在法国和苏格兰之间，玛丽与法国国王的婚姻是其伟大的象征，即所谓的“老同盟”。所以他说，好吧，如果我能用苏格兰与英格兰的联盟取代苏格兰与法国的联盟会怎样？这看起来可能是一个巨大的挑战，因为苏格兰和英格兰几代人以来一直是世仇，但他并不认为这是不可能的。他像面对巨大挑战时一样，做他总是做的事情，即本质上起草一份备忘录，并以要点形式列出所有论点。所以他写道，必须确保苏格兰不像现在这样受法国的指派，因为法国是英格兰的古老
enemy to England seeketh always to make Scotland an instrument to exercise thereby their malice upon England and to make a footstool thereof to look over England as they may. So Scotland is a French dagger pointed and he recognises keen Protestant that he is and very shrewd and analyst of international affairs that what needs to be done is to support the Protestant cause in Scotland. and his vision is of a united Protestant Britain and he writes that thereby this famous isle, i.e. Britain, may be conjoined in one uniformity of language, manners and conditions. He's a British visionary.
敌人，总是寻求使苏格兰成为工具，从而对英格兰施加恶意，并将其作为垫脚石，以便在他们可能的时候俯瞰英格兰。所以苏格兰是一把指向英格兰的法国匕首，他认识到，作为一个敏锐的新教徒，以及对国际事务非常精明的分析家，需要做的是支持苏格兰的新教事业。他的愿景是一个统一的新教英国，他写道，从而这个著名的岛屿，即英国，可以在语言、习俗和条件上统一起来。他是一位英国的远见者。
However, what would that would require would be effectively a policy of foreign intervention, right? Liberal intervention in overseas. Or Protestant intervention. Yeah. And Elizabeth doesn't like that because she knows, A, wars are expensive, and also a war is a kind of policy commitment, and her entire reign is basically an exercise in shrinking from policy commitments, right?
然而，这将需要实际上是一种外国干预政策，对吧？海外的自由主义干预。或者新教干预。是的。而伊丽莎白不喜欢那样，因为她知道，A，战争是昂贵的，而且战争是一种政策承诺，而她的整个统治基本上就是一种回避政策承诺的练习，对吧？
And just kicking the can down the road. So Cecil the whole time is basically pushing and kind of trying to cajole her into some form of intervention in Scottish politics. And basically what she finally agrees, what's this, 1560, they can do it financially. They will send money to the Protestants camp. in Scotland. Yeah, so finally she surrenders. I mean, at one point, Cecil had been threatening to resign, and she does kind of give in. And so money and arms start heading northwards to help the Protestants overthrow, not just the Catholics, but the French Catholics who are in hold
只是把问题拖延下去。所以塞西尔一直在基本上推动并试图哄骗她进行某种形式的苏格兰政治干预。基本上她最终同意了，这是什么时候，1560年，他们可以在经济上做到这一点。他们将向苏格兰的新教阵营提供资金。是的，所以最终她投降了。我的意思是，有一次，塞西尔一直在威胁要辞职，而她确实屈服了。所以金钱和武器开始向北运送，以帮助新教徒推翻，不仅是天主教徒，还有那些掌权的法国天主教徒。
of France, one of whom is Mary Queen of Scott's mother, Mary of Geese, who dies in the course of this campaign. And the result by the first week of July in 1560 is one of the superfluous. triumphs of Cecil's entire career. And this is a treaty that is signed by himself in person. He's written up to the Scottish capital, but also by Scottish and French representatives. And because it's signed in Edinburgh, it's called the Treaty of Edinburgh. And basically, it gives Cecil everything he had dreamed of getting. So the French agreed to withdraw from Scotland. They are gone. But even more crucially, the French recognise Elizabeth as queen. And so that then essentially kind of kneecaps any prospect of Mary Queen of Scots having French
法国，其中一位是苏格兰玛丽女王的母亲，吉斯的玛丽，她在这次战役中去世。1560年7月的第一周，结果是塞西尔整个职业生涯中最辉煌的胜利之一。这是一份由他本人亲自签署的条约。他不仅写信给苏格兰首都，还由苏格兰和法国代表签署。因为它是在爱丁堡签署的，所以被称为《爱丁堡条约》。基本上，它给了塞西尔他梦寐以求的一切。法国人同意从苏格兰撤军。他们离开了。但更关键的是，法国人承认伊丽莎白为女王。这基本上扼杀了苏格兰玛丽女王拥有法国支持以对抗伊丽莎白而宣称拥有英格兰王位的任何前景。
support for her claim to the English throne against Elizabeth. And then a month after the Treaty of Edinburgh, there's another amazing triumph for Cecil because the Scottish Parliament meets and effectively disestablishes the Catholic Church, repudiates the papal supremacy, enshrines Protestantism as the state religion in Scotland. And this dream that Cecil has had of a Protestant island of England and Scotland united in a kind of the commonality of true religion seems almost to have been achieved. And these are two absolutely decisive victories. And they serve to keep Mary kind of in her box. Because with the French recognition of her claim to the English throne gone, what is she getting out of the French alliance? And the seal is set
在《爱丁堡条约》签署一个月后，塞西尔又取得了另一个惊人的胜利，因为苏格兰议会召开会议，有效地废除了天主教会，否认了教皇的至高无上地位，并将新教确立为苏格兰的国教。塞西尔一直梦想的英格兰和苏格兰在一种共同的真正宗教中联合起来的那个新教岛屿的梦想似乎几乎已经实现。这是两场绝对决定性的胜利。它们起到了将玛丽限制在她的范围内的作用。因为随着法国人不再承认她对英格兰王位的要求，她从法国联盟中得到了什么？而且，随着1560年底她丈夫因耳朵爆炸而去世，她在法国政治中作为一名参与者的有效无能被盖棺定论。听过我们关于苏格兰玛丽女王那一集的人可能还记得，脓液开始从他的耳朵和鼻孔里喷出来，这一切都非常可怕。所以她现在不再是法国的女王了。那里的游戏结束了，所以1561年8月，她回到了苏格兰。在那里，她发现她的王国牢牢地掌握在新教机构的手中。你知道，这是塞西尔的另一个伟大胜利。他帮助在苏格兰玛丽女王王国的中心建立了虔诚的宗教。
on her effective impotence as a player in French politics, at the end of 1560, when her husband dies of an exploding ear, people who listen to our episode on Mary Queen of Scots may remember that pus starts shooting out of his ear and his nostrils, and it's all very horrible. So she is now no longer queen in France. The game is up there, and so in August 1561, she returns to Scotland. And there she finds that her kingdom is firmly in the grip of a Protestant establishment. You know, this is Cecil's other great victory. He's helped to establish godly religion in the heart of Mary Queen of Scots' kingdom.
（注：此段落内容在输入中与71段落末尾重叠，已根据上下文逻辑进行翻译）
And Mary Queen of Scots, when she arrives in Edinburgh, does not do a Mary Tudor. She does not attempt to roll this back. She does not attempt to reinstitute Catholicism. And so Scotland remains Protestant. despite having a Catholic queen, and this enables it to constitute a crucial building block in Cecil's strategy for keeping Elizabeth and Protestantism in England secure. So, you know, this unitary Protestant identity that Scotland and England now share enables a diplomatic alliance between these two old rivals, England and Scotland.
苏格兰玛丽女王到达爱丁堡时，并没有像玛丽·都铎那样行事。她没有试图扭转局面。她没有试图恢复天主教。因此，尽管有一位天主教女王，苏格兰仍然保持新教，这使它成为塞西尔确保英格兰伊丽莎白和新教安全的战略中的一个关键基石。所以，你知道，苏格兰和英格兰现在共享的这种单一的新教身份，使得这两个老对手英格兰和苏格兰之间能够建立外交联盟。
Antichrist basically is being kept at bay, and at the same time, Cecil's mistress is more secure on her throne. So it's brilliant. Win, win, win. That's great, because that's everything we want, because it basically paves the way for the creation of the kingdom of Gate Britain, eventually more than a century later. But also, we love keeping the Antichrist at bay.
反基督者基本上被拒之门外，同时，塞西尔的女主人在她的王位上也更加稳固。所以这太棒了。三赢。这太好了，因为这是我们想要的一切，因为它基本上为后来一个多世纪后大不列颠王国的建立铺平了道路。而且，我们也喜欢把反基督者拒之门外。
So that's great news. However, the Antichrist, you can never completely discount him, can you? I mean, you can never get rid of him completely. He's always lurking there. And I guess the fear is, you know, could the Antichrist return or who knows what might happen if Elizabeth dies? Because this issue of the air. So in 1562, Elizabeth gets smallpox, doesn't she? And people think Elizabeth is for the chop. She might die. And so if you are Cecil and the rest of the political elite, what's your answer to this? Because you obviously don't want Mary Queen of Scots. But who do you want? Who is left? I mean, this is a massive, massive. problem for them. It is. It's a huge problem. And so a few months after that scare with the smallpox in March 1563, he draws up a bill that is astonishingly bold. I mean, one might almost say bold to a revolutionary degree. So it pointedly excludes Mary Stewart from the line
所以这是个好消息。然而，反基督者，你永远不能完全忽视他，对吧？我的意思是，你永远无法完全摆脱他。他总是潜伏在那里。我想人们担心的是，你知道，如果伊丽莎白去世，反基督者会回来吗？或者谁知道会发生什么？因为继承人的问题。所以1562年，伊丽莎白得了天花，不是吗？人们认为伊丽莎白要完了。她可能会死。所以如果你是塞西尔和其余的政治精英，你的答案是什么？因为你显然不想要苏格兰玛丽女王。但你想要谁？还剩下谁？我的意思是，这对他们来说是一个巨大的、巨大的问题。确实。这是一个巨大的问题。所以在天花恐慌发生几个月后的1563年3月，他起草了一项令人震惊的大胆法案。我的意思是，人们几乎可以说大胆到了革命性的程度。它明确地将玛丽·斯图尔特排除在继承顺序之外。
of succession. The line of succession is drawn up and it's a Protestant one. And most startling of all, it legislates for the council, so Elizabeth's privy council, in the event of the Queen's death, to be entrusted with emergency powers. And Stephen Orford in his biography of Cecil spells what these powers would be. Cecil proposed that if Elizabeth died without a successor, the Queen's divine authority to govern would be transferred not to an heir, but to her privy council, and England would become, for a time, an aristocratic republic. And as Alford points out, this is to anticipate by 150 years the glorious revolution,
继承顺序被起草出来，而且是一个新教的顺序。最令人吃惊的是，它为议会立法，即伊丽莎白的枢密院，在女王去世的情况下，被赋予紧急权力。斯蒂芬·奥尔福德在塞西尔的传记中阐述了这些权力是什么。塞西尔提议，如果伊丽莎白在没有继承人的情况下去世，女王统治的神圣权力将不会转移给继承人，而是转移给她的枢密院，英格兰将暂时成为一个贵族共和国。正如奥尔福德指出的那样，这是提前150年预见了光荣革命，
which sees the Catholic James II kind of chucked off the throne and a Protestant king replacing him. And it's a kind of gobsmacking manoeuvre in the context of mid-16th century England. But as Alford also points out, this is not an expression of kind of crypto-Republicanism. There is, I think, a slight trend in historians studying the reign of Elizabeth to kind of describe it as a Republican monarchy. I don't think that that is the case at all. Elizabeth always remains queen. She's very conscious of her prerogatives.
那场革命见证了天主教徒詹姆斯二世被赶下王位，由一位新教国王取代他。在16世纪中叶的英格兰背景下，这是一种令人目瞪口呆的策略。但正如奥尔福德也指出的那样，这并不是一种隐秘的共和主义的表达。我认为，在研究伊丽莎白统治时期的历史学家中，有一种轻微的趋势，将其描述为共和君主制。我根本不认为情况是这样。伊丽莎白始终是女王。她非常清楚自己的特权。
And I think that her court and Cecil and everybody is very conscious of it as well. So Orford has a brilliant comparison with actually what Cecil is doing here. He says that it's, you know, basically it's Cecil's duty to prepare for the worst. like modern government's planning for nuclear apocalypse, it is incredible that he could bring himself to imagine a scenario so horrific. So he is thinking, okay, if the absolute worst happens, what then do we do? So he's thinking the unthinkable, but actually Elizabeth doesn't allow it to pass. She says there's no way that my power will pass to you guys.
我认为她的宫廷、塞西尔和每个人也都非常清楚这一点。所以奥尔福德对塞西尔在这里所做的事情有一个精彩的比较。他说，这基本上是塞西尔为最坏情况做准备的职责。就像现代政府为核灾难做计划一样，他竟然能想象出如此可怕的场景，这真是令人难以置信。所以他在想，好吧，如果发生了最坏的情况，我们该怎么办？所以他在思考不可想象的事情，但实际上伊丽莎白并没有让它通过。她说，我的权力绝不可能移交给你们这些人。
Now, part of this is not just his fear for the succession, is it? It's his fear that Elizabeth is actually going to do something very drastic and very inappropriate and rash and reckless. That's the irony of it. Because he's infuriated not just by her, you know, customary prevarications, but also by the prospect that she might actually do what everyone's been pressing her to do and get married. And get married, right.
现在，这部分不仅是因为他对继承权的恐惧，不是吗？这是他担心伊丽莎白实际上会做出一些非常激烈、非常不恰当、鲁莽和轻率的事情。这就是讽刺之处。因为他不仅被她习惯性的推诿所激怒，还被她可能真的会做每个人都一直在敦促她做的事情——结婚——的前景所激怒。而且是结婚，对吧。
So this is the thing with Elizabeth, isn't it? This is the tension that it's one of the fun elements of her whole story, that although she's incredibly cool and pragmatic and shrewd and all of this, she is still a creature of flesh and blood. And she has a succession of kind of infatuations or crushes on people that everybody else regards as absolutely inappropriate and definitely not the right person for her to be considering as a husband. So in 1562 when she was ill, she had named a protector if she were to die. And this is somebody that we've mentioned, or certainly from a family that we've mentioned, which is Robert Douglass. So tell us about Robert Dudley.
所以这就是伊丽莎白的问题，不是吗？这就是紧张局势，这是她整个故事中有趣的元素之一，尽管她非常冷静、务实、精明，所有这些，但她仍然是一个有血有肉的人。她对一系列人产生过迷恋或暗恋，而其他人认为这些人绝对是不合适的，绝对不是她应该考虑作为丈夫的人。所以1562年她生病时，她曾指定了一位保护者，以防她去世。这就是我们提到过的人，或者至少来自我们提到过的家庭，即罗伯特·达德利。那么告诉我们关于罗伯特·达德利的事。
So Robert Dudley, we've mentioned him briefly in the previous episodes, but not in such a way that he's probably seared on people's minds. So just a recap, he's the son of the Earl of Northumberland, who had been busy promoting Lady Jane Grey as queen and had ended up executed by Mary Tudor. He was a childhood friend of Elizabeth. When Elizabeth gets sent to the tower in the wake of Wyatt's rebellion by Mary, Robert Dudley is there as well, for the same reason he's suspected. of complicity in Wyatt's rebellion. Both of them get freed, of course. They remain very close in the dying days of Mary's reign. And Robert Dudley is a very, very good-looking, glamorous, swaggering man.
所以罗伯特·达德利，我们在之前的剧集中简要提到过他，但并没有让他给人们留下深刻印象。所以简单回顾一下，他是诺森伯兰伯爵的儿子，他曾忙于推举简·格雷夫人为女王，最终被玛丽·都铎处决。他是伊丽莎白的童年朋友。当伊丽莎白在玛丽发动的怀亚特叛乱后被送往塔楼时，罗伯特·达德利也在那里，原因相同，他被怀疑参与了怀亚特叛乱。当然，他们两个都被释放了。在玛丽统治的最后日子里，他们仍然非常亲密。罗伯特·达德利是一个非常、非常英俊、迷人、昂首阔步的男人。
And contemporaries note that Robert Dudley strongly resembled Thomas Seymour, who was her very hansy stepfather, Mr. Tickle, the man who had basically introduced the young Elizabeth to the dimension of adult sexuality. And perhaps that had kind of imprinted a certain type on Elizabeth's imaginings, but definitely Thomas Seymour, Robert Dudley, they're all kind of men of a certain kind. Roysterers. They're roisterers, but they're kind of charismatic and physically attractive.
同时代的人注意到罗伯特·达德利非常像托马斯·西摩，那是她非常英俊的继父，蒂克尔先生，那个基本上把年轻的伊丽莎白引入成人性维度的人。也许这在某种程度上给伊丽莎白的想象力留下了某种印记，但毫无疑问，托马斯·西摩、罗伯特·达德利，他们都是某种类型的人。狂欢者。他们是狂欢者，但他们很有魅力，身体上很有吸引力。
And when Elizabeth becomes queen, she appoints Robert Dudley as her master of horse, and that is a role that gives him a kind of exceptional degree of closeness and intimacy. because as Master of Horse, he helps her up into her stirrups, which means that he can touch her. He is also given rooms next to her privy chamber, very much a kind of a female dimension, but Dudley is there very close. And she's seen on several occasions to be kind of surprisingly intimate with him.
当伊丽莎白成为女王时，她任命罗伯特·达德利为她的马厩总管，这个角色给了他一种非凡的亲密程度。因为作为马厩总管，他帮助她上马镫，这意味着他可以触碰她。他还被分配了靠近她私室的房间，这在很大程度上是一种女性维度，但达德利就在那里，非常近。而且人们多次看到她对他表现出令人惊讶的亲密。
So there's one occasion she's seen running her fingers over his neck. On another, she mops his brow with a handkerchief. after he's finished a tennis match. And I think the mutual attraction between them is very evident. And so maybe Elizabeth is thinking, well, you know, why shouldn't I, I marry him? Well, there are two obvious reasons why she shouldn't marry him. So a blindingly obvious one is the moment that she marries him, everybody will hate him. And this will cause her enormous problems.
所以有一次，人们看到她用手指抚摸他的脖子。另一次，在他打完网球后，她用手帕擦拭他的额头。我认为他们之间的相互吸引力非常明显。所以也许伊丽莎白在想，好吧，你知道，我为什么不嫁给他呢？好吧，她不应该嫁给他的两个明显原因。所以一个极其明显的原因是，她嫁给他的那一刻，每个人都会恨他。这将给她带来巨大的问题。
There'll be too many. It's that classic thing that politicians face. When you promote one person, you disappoint all the rivals. and as soon as she does this, surely the chances of rebellion or faction fighting at court will be massively magnified. Exactly, because if the problem with marrying a foreign prince is that it risks locking England into a kind of permanent alliance, the problem with marrying someone from the English aristocracy is, as you say, that it will kind of foster internal dissension, and that is
会有太多人。这是政治家面临的经典问题。当你提拔一个人时，你会让所有的竞争对手失望。一旦她这样做，叛乱或宫廷派系斗争的可能性肯定会大大增加。没错，因为如果嫁给外国王子的问题在于它有将英格兰锁定在某种永久联盟中的风险，那么嫁给英国贵族的问题正如你所说，在于它会助长内部不和，而这正是
a massive threat. She would remember how everyone hated the Berlin's, everyone hated the Woodville's, you know, that's what would happen now. Yes. There's also a further problem specific to Robert Dudley, which is that by the early 1560s, he is darkly suspected by his enemies of having murdered his wife. And that also is obviously not a good look. So this was a woman called Amy Robsart, who he'd married in 1550.
一个巨大的威胁。她会记得每个人是如何憎恨博林家族的，每个人是如何憎恨伍德维尔家族的，你知道，现在会发生同样的事情。是的。罗伯特·达德利还有一个具体的问题，那就是到16世纪60年代初，他的敌人们阴暗地怀疑他谋杀了他的妻子。这显然也不是什么好事。所以这是一个叫艾米·罗布萨特的女人，他在1550年娶了她。
But by 1560, so just over a year after Elizabeth had become queen, Dudley is never with Amy. He's spending his whole time with Elizabeth. And then on the 8th of September, 1560, Amy was found dead at the foot of a staircase in their Oxfordshire home in Kumner. And she died of head injuries and a broken back. An inquest was held. Robert Dudley demanded that a full inquiry be made
但到了1560年，也就是伊丽莎白成为女王一年多后，达德利从不和艾米在一起。他把所有时间都花在伊丽莎白身上。然后在1560年9月8日，艾米被发现死在他们位于牛津郡库姆纳的家中的楼梯底部。她死于头部受伤和脊椎骨折。进行了调查。罗伯特·达德利要求进行全面调查，
because he was anxious that he might be accused of the murder. And sure enough, the verdict was that Amy had fallen down the stairs, that her death had been accidental. And it's certainly the case that Dudley couldn't have pushed her because inevitably he was with Elizabeth at the time. He was not in Cumberner. He was in Windsor. But it's perfect for his enemies.
因为他担心自己会被指控谋杀。果然，裁决是艾米从楼梯上摔了下来，她的死是意外。达德利肯定不可能推她，因为当时他不可避免地和伊丽莎白在一起。他不在库姆纳。他在温莎。但这对他来说是完美的敌人。
It gives him an ideal way to blacken his name. And so they're endlessly kind of promoting rumors that he had commissioned the murder. They're fanning the accusation that he's a murderer of his wife. And so this is a massive blot. But I suspect that even if he hadn't had this, you know, this accusation of murder hanging over him, Elizabeth still wouldn't have married him. And the reasons for that, I mean, there are many reasons why Elizabeth wasn't going to marry anyway, but specifically, too many people that she depends on are saying, don't do it. So one of these is Kat Ashley, the woman probably that she
这给了他们一个抹黑他名字的理想方式。所以他们无休止地散布他委托谋杀的谣言。他们煽动他是杀妻凶手的指控。所以这是一个巨大的污点。但我怀疑即使他没有这个，你知道，这个谋杀指控悬在他头上，伊丽莎白仍然不会嫁给他。原因，我的意思是，伊丽莎白无论如何都不会结婚有很多原因，但具体来说，她依赖的太多人都在说，不要这样做。所以其中之一是凯特·阿什利，那个她
trusted and loved more than anyone else in existence. And on one occasion, Kat flings herself at the feet of Elizabeth and declares that she would rather have strangled Elizabeth in her cradle than allow her to marry such a man as Dudley. And the other person who makes it very clear that he disapproves is Cecil. And he says bluntly to Elizabeth, if you marry him, then I'm going to resign. But I think ultimately it's Elizabeth herself who pulls back from the brink because she knows the costs. She can evaluate them. And even to marry someone that she is as obviously devoted to as Dudley, it's still a commitment of exactly the kind that she has always shrunk from. And so in 1564, rather than Mary Dudley, she pushes an astonishing proposal.
信任和爱超过世上任何人的女人。有一次，凯特扑倒在伊丽莎白脚下，宣称她宁愿在摇篮里勒死伊丽莎白，也不愿让她嫁给达德利这样的人。另一个明确表示不赞成的人是塞西尔。他直截了当地对伊丽莎白说，如果你嫁给他，那我就辞职。但我认为最终是伊丽莎白自己从边缘退了回来，因为她知道代价。她可以评估它们。即使是嫁给一个她显然像达德利那样投入的人，这仍然是她一直回避的那种承诺。所以1564年，她没有嫁给达德利，而是提出了一个惊人的建议。
And this is a proposal that we didn't mention in our series on Mary Queen of Scots because I was saving it for this series. She proposes that Dudley should go north to Scotland and there become the husband of Mary Queen of Scots. And to make it a more tempting match for Mary, she gives Dudley this magnificent title, The Earl of Leicester. Well, that really is a splendid title because, you know, love Lester on this show, don't we? So what on earth is Elizabeth thinking? I mean, that seems mad. I guess although that said, if she sent a very, very loyal English Protestant to Scotland,
这是一个我们在苏格兰玛丽女王系列中没有提到的建议，因为我把它留给了这个系列。她提议达德利应该去北方的苏格兰，在那里成为苏格兰玛丽女王的丈夫。为了让这对玛丽来说是一个更诱人的匹配，她给了达德利这个宏伟的头衔，莱斯特伯爵。嗯，那确实是一个辉煌的头衔，因为，你知道，在这个节目中我们喜欢莱斯特，不是吗？所以伊丽莎白到底在想什么？我的意思是，这看起来很疯狂。我想虽然话虽如此，如果她派了一个非常、非常忠诚的英国新教徒去苏格兰，
I guess that works kind of diplomatically. Yeah, and also if they then have children, then, you know, the heir to the throne might then become a, you know, the son of Lester. And again, perhaps there are kind of deep psychological waters. I mean, and perhaps actually It's an expression of Elizabeth's own frustration and yearning as a virgin queen. I mean, maybe she's wanting Mary kind of bicariously to play the role that she herself would have loved to have had, you know, the wife of less. I mean, it is a very odd proposal, a very odd episode. And perhaps it's not surprising that Mary Queen of Scots turns it down and goes on, of course,
我想这在外交上是行得通的。是的，而且如果他们后来有了孩子，那么，你知道，王位的继承人可能就会成为，你知道，莱斯特的儿子。而且，也许有某种深层的心理水域。我的意思是，也许实际上这是伊丽莎白作为处女女王对自己挫折和渴望的表达。我的意思是，也许她想让玛丽以某种代理的方式扮演她自己本来很想扮演的角色，你知道，莱斯特的妻子。我的意思是，这是一个非常奇怪的提议，一个非常奇怪的插曲。苏格兰玛丽女王拒绝了它，当然继续下去，也就不足为奇了，
to opt for too spectacularly our suitable husbands in succession. And if you want to find out just how unsuitable they were, and you haven't listened to our series on Mary Queen of Scots do, because honestly, the story is mad. So first of all, she marries Darnley, the biggest cock in British history, who ends up, his house ends up getting blown up, and he's found very mysterious in a side garden with a chair next to it. All very odd.
为了选择我们合适的丈夫而接连做出极其引人注目的决定。如果你想知道他们有多么不合适，而且你还没有听过我们关于苏格兰玛丽女王的系列节目，一定要去听，因为说实话，那个故事太疯狂了。首先，她嫁给了达恩利，英国历史上最混蛋的人，他的房子最后被炸毁了，他被发现以一种非常神秘的方式躺在旁边的花园里，旁边还有一把椅子。这一切都非常奇怪。
And then Bothwell, who basically adducks her, rapes her and then marries her. So, which is a kind of example of what Elizabeth was sparing herself when she turned down Lester. And it's the marker of how in every way Elizabeth is a much astute a player, a more self-disciplined player than Mary ever was. And the result of all this, so I mean,
然后是博斯韦尔，他基本上绑架了她，强奸了她，然后娶了她。所以，这算是伊丽莎白拒绝莱斯特时所避免的一种情况。这标志着伊丽莎白在各方面都比玛丽更精明、更自律。这一切的结果是，我的意思是，
first of all, it's a massive object lesson and what happens if you, you know, you make the choice and the choice goes wrong. But the result of it is that in 1568, Mary basically is kicked out. She's in England. She's come south.
首先，这是一个巨大的反面教材，告诉你如果你做出了选择，而选择又错了会发生什么。但结果是，1568年，玛丽基本上被赶了出来。她在英格兰，她来到了南方。
And suddenly, in England, you have a Catholic, you know, a Catholic claimant, a Catholic heroine, a focus for everybody who disapproves of Elizabeth, disapproves of her Protestantism, disapproves of her regime. And suddenly Mary Queen of Scots has turned up. And she's right there. You know, you could put her on the, you could get rid of Elizabeth, put her on the phone, and for Elizabeth, this is a massive deal. Yeah.
突然之间，在英格兰，你拥有了一位天主教的竞争者，一位天主教的女英雄，一个让所有反对伊丽莎白、反对她的新教信仰、反对她的政权的人聚集的焦点。突然间，苏格兰玛丽女王出现了。她就在那里。你知道，你可以把她放在……你可以除掉伊丽莎白，让她上位，对伊丽莎白来说，这是一件大事。是的。
And I think when Mary arrives, she doesn't realize it. but she constitutes an absolutely mortal threat to Elizabeth and to her Protestant regime in a way that she hadn't really done while she was ruling as Queen in Scotland. And so the huge question is, what is Elizabeth going to do? Is she going to tolerate this? What about Cecil? You know, Cecil has devoted his entire life to overthrowing Mary. And now she's a prisoner in England.
我认为玛丽到达时，她自己并没有意识到，但她对伊丽莎白和她的新教政权构成了绝对的致命威胁，这与她在苏格兰担任女王时的情况完全不同。所以最大的问题是，伊丽莎白会怎么做？她会容忍吗？塞西尔呢？你知道，塞西尔毕生致力于推翻玛丽。现在她是英格兰的囚犯。
Will Mary become a focus for conspiracy? if she does, what resources of espionage and skullduggery is Cecil going to have to depend on to foil Mary's plots? And what will this deadly game of cat and mouse mean for the Catholics of England, for the Pope, for the greatest Catholic king of the age, Philip I of Spain as he is now, where might this flux of conspiracy and plotting and spying, where might it lead to? And Dominic, we will find out in a new series next year, The Tudor Cold War. We'll be looking at the conspiracies that Mary Queen of Scots launches against Elizabeth, the espionage deployed by Cecil and his spy chief, Sir Francis Walsingham, to counter Catholic
玛丽会成为阴谋的焦点吗？如果她成了，塞西尔将不得不依赖什么样的间谍活动和诡计来挫败玛丽的阴谋？这场致命的猫鼠游戏对英格兰的天主教徒、对教皇、对当时最伟大的天主教国王——现在的西班牙国王菲利普二世意味着什么？这种阴谋、策划和间谍活动的洪流可能会导致什么结果？多米尼克，我们将在明年的新系列《都铎冷战》中找到答案。我们将审视苏格兰玛丽女王针对伊丽莎白发起的阴谋，以及塞西尔和他的间谍头目弗朗西斯·沃尔辛厄姆爵士为反击天主教而部署的间谍活动，
plotting, the engagement of the Spanish in the low countries and the process of events that culminates with the execution of Mary Queen of Scots in Fotheringay Castle and then in due course we will be coming to the spectacular story of the Spanish Armada. But all that, Dominic, lies in the future. So much to look forward to on the rest is history. Now, you may be wondering what could be more exciting than the Tudor Cold War in the Spanish Armada? The answer is basically practically nothing, especially if it's going to be told Tom with as much dazzling skill as you brought to this series. However, the good news is for the members of the Restus History Club and others,
策划，西班牙在低地国家的介入，以及最终导致苏格兰玛丽女王在福瑟林盖城堡被处决的事件进程，随后我们将讲述西班牙无敌舰队的壮观故事。但多米尼克，这一切都在未来。在《历史的其余部分》中，还有很多值得期待的内容。现在，你可能想知道还有什么比都铎冷战和西班牙无敌舰队更令人兴奋的吗？答案是基本上什么都没有，特别是如果它是由你带给这个系列的令人眼花缭乱的技巧来讲述的话。然而，好消息是，对于《历史的其余部分》俱乐部的成员和其他人来说，
that Christmas is coming early, or rather the New Year, is coming early, because Tom especially is a very generous and kind-hearted person. We decided to give you your presents early this year. So next week we'll be returning with what's usually a first. festive treat. It's the story of the Nazis. And we will be looking particularly at Hitler's invasion of Western Europe and what that meant. So we'll be in late 1939 and early 1940. The spring and summer of 1940, one of the most dramatic stories in modern history. Of course, if you want to get all of that series right away on Monday, you merely need to join the Restis
圣诞节来得早，或者说新年提前到了，因为汤姆特别是一个非常慷慨和善良的人。我们决定今年提前给你们送礼物。所以下周我们将回归，带来通常是首选的节日款待。这是关于纳粹的故事。我们将特别关注希特勒对西欧的入侵及其意义。所以我们将处于1939年底和1940年初。1940年的春天和夏天，现代史上最戏剧性的故事之一。当然，如果你想在周一立即获得整个系列，你只需要加入《历史的其余部分》
History Club at the Restis History.com. Right. So Tom, Thank you very much. That was a genuine toorder force. And on that bombshell, goodbye, everybody. Goodbye. stories from the world of secrets and spars. And this time we are delving into the dark and twisted story of the man who dared to challenge Vladimir Putin, Yevgeny Progossian, and the ruthless war machine he built the Wagner Group. From Putin's chef to mercenary warlord, Progoshin's journey is one of the most extraordinary rises and balls of the 21st century. He went from serving canopets to George Bush and Tony Blair to masterminding a covert campaign to disrupt the U.S. presidential election
历史俱乐部，网址是therestishistory.com。好的。那么汤姆，非常感谢。那真是一次精彩的表演。带着这个重磅消息，再见，大家。再见。来自秘密和间谍世界的故事。这一次，我们正在深入挖掘那个敢于挑战弗拉基米尔·普京的人——叶夫根尼·普里戈任，以及他建立的无情战争机器——瓦格纳集团，那段黑暗而扭曲的故事。从普京的厨师到雇佣兵军阀，普里戈任的旅程是21世纪最非凡的兴衰史之一。他从为乔治·布什和托尼·布莱尔提供餐点，到策划一场秘密运动以干扰美国总统选举
in 2016 and unleashing mercenary troops that reshaped conflicts across Africa and the Middle East. But when he flies too close to the sun and begins to challenge Putin's power, it's not just ambition, it is a death wish. And for our declassified club members, we go even further. We sat down with Mark Galiati, who's one of the leading experts on Russian organized crime and also a man banned from entering Russia to explore the hidden forces that shape Putin's cold, paranoid psyche and the forces that threatened to take him down. If this sounds good, listen to the rest is classified wherever you get your podcast. Throughout time, celebration has meant to
在2016年，并释放了重塑非洲和中东冲突的雇佣兵部队。但当他飞得太靠近太阳并开始挑战普京的权力时，这不仅仅是野心，这是一种死亡愿望。对于我们的解密俱乐部成员，我们走得更远。我们与俄罗斯有组织犯罪领域的顶尖专家之一、同时也是被禁止进入俄罗斯的马克·加莱奥蒂坐下来，探讨塑造普京冷酷、偏执心理的隐藏力量，以及威胁要推翻他的力量。如果这听起来不错，请在任何你获取播客的地方收听《历史的其余部分：解密》。纵观历史，庆祝活动意味着
giving. So the Romans at Saturnalia handed out all kinds of gifts. The three magi handed out gold, frankincense and myrrh, and the Victorians absolutely loved wrapping things up in paper and then tying it up in string. So on those are lovely gestures, but I wonder if they're a little bit too extravagant for the typical Christmas morning. So this year, here's my suggestion to our listeners and our viewers, why not give something a little bit more enlightened? Why not give the gift of the Rest is History Club membership. It's the discerning choice for anybody who prefers a Hannibal to a hamper. It's ad-free listening.
给予。所以罗马人在农神节分发各种礼物。三位智者分发了黄金、乳香和没药，维多利亚时代的人绝对喜欢用纸把东西包起来，然后用绳子系好。所以这些都是可爱的姿态，但我怀疑它们对于典型的圣诞早晨来说是否有点太奢侈了。所以今年，这是我对我们的听众和观众的建议，为什么不送一些更有启发性的东西呢？为什么不送一份《历史的其余部分》俱乐部会员资格作为礼物呢？对于任何喜欢汉尼拔胜过喜欢礼品篮的人来说，这是一个有眼光的选择。它是无广告收听。
You get a weekly bonus episode. You get early access to live shows. And you get exclusive deep dive series. Also, on top of that, this year's special gift edition of Restis History Club membership comes with a sensational exclusive t-shirt. It will make you the envy of all your names. and all the cool people in your neighborhood, if such people exist, will admire you and want to spend more time with you. So just head to therestishistory.com and click on gifts. That is
你每周会得到一集额外节目。你可以提前获得现场演出的门票。你还可以获得独家深度系列节目。此外，今年《历史的其余部分》俱乐部会员资格的特别礼品版还附带一件轰动性的独家T恤。它会让你成为所有朋友羡慕的对象，你邻居里所有酷的人，如果这样的人存在的话，都会钦佩你并想花更多时间和你在一起。所以只需前往therestishistory.com并点击礼品。那就是
therestishistory.com and please click on gifts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
therestishistory.com，请点击礼品。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。